the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
we've passed the Midway point at the
superbet chess classic in Bucharest
Romania with the rest day Insight
players went for broke and left it all
on the boards world champion ding lahren
accepted his first loss under his new
title after falling to a surging alaresa
farrugia despite looking lost Maxine
Bashir lagrav came from behind to hand
Jan naponiacci his second consecutive
loss caruana Paces the field by half a
point can he be caught day six of
classical chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everybody to day six of the
2023 Superbad chess classic Health here
in Bucharest Romania we start the day in
front of an iconic church here in the
center of Bucharest the church adornira
maichi Donnelly also known as the
kratzulesku church we've had some
fantastic Fighting Chess up to this
point what do the players have in store
for us let's go to the studio in St
Louis and find out
we will welcome you to the first stop on
the 2023 grandchild store and our
coverage of superbed Romania we come to
you live from the San Luis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone thanks for
joining us again I'm International
Master Nazi paikideze and I'm here with
my brilliant co-host yes I'm not so sure
about the brilliant part but it's a
pleasure to be with you Nancy what have
you done on your estate I went to the
zoo and spent the day with animals it
was really nice
so nothing changes right hello everyone
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage we are in round six and
boy that was a much appreciated rest day
as I'm sure the players have recharged
their batteries and are ready for the
Sprint to the Finish four rounds to go
tell us about the standings now see do
the honors please all right let's take a
look we have a soul leader American
Fabiano caruana with three and a half
points closely following firuja Wesley
so and Richard rapper quite the chasing
pack
and with 50 we have Anish giri and mvl
with two points Yani promise
of Tuda wow champion and Challenger at
two points that looks like a misprint
boy that is just amazing and with one
one and a half backdandiac and our
format
we have a 10 player round robin
tournament with a classical time control
90 minutes for the first 40 moves 30
minutes for the rest of the game with 30
second increment from move one
no draw offers allowed and the scoring
system is one point for a win half for a
draw and zero for a loss National
Brilliance system and our remaining
schedule nice
right we have four more rounds to go
players will be playing around six today
and the tournament will end on Monday
May 15th outstanding and as always we're
delighted to have in studio Rouge
nicobian Barr very nice to see you this
morning how are you doing and how did
you spend your rest day
good morning guys I had a very nice rest
day spent some time with family and now
we're back to see the round six of this
very exciting tournament and Fabiano is
in the lead but there are three people
behind him so I think still a lot of
chairs to be played and we have an
incredibly strong field let's take a
look at the rankings of these players
the live rankings so we have Jane
promenation number two currently ding
Loren number three alireza fusion number
four number six Anish giri number five
actually is Hikaru Nakamura who is not
playing in this tournament then we have
number seven Fabiano caruana and
Westchester and of course number one
player in the world Magnus Carlson he's
missing in this event but he will be
playing in the upcoming GCT uh rapid and
Blitz tournament in in Warsaw Poland
let's take a look at their appearances
in a candidates tournament and the world
championship matches so we have dingler
in two appearances in the candidates
tournament and one and one in a world
championship and he is the current world
chess champion he had one chance and he
managed to win the match against nepo
nepo won two candidate tournaments but
unfortunately both matches he lost so he
will be looking forward for the next
candidate tournament to have another
shot Fabiano caruana most appearances in
the candidates tournament and he won and
played for the world championship match
since 2018 but unfortunately lost
against Magnus house and other players
also had appearances on ishigiri head 2
and most of in other players had only
one and except uh Bogdan Daniel dick and
we're gonna go to Romania to our
colleague Grandmaster Christian chirilla
thanks far and welcome back chess fans
to Bucharest Romania for the start of a
day six here at the Superbad chess
classic what an event we've had so far
we've passed the midpoint of the
tournament and right now the action is
hitting up and we have some
mouth-watering matchups for you guys you
highlighted our uh dingley Ren of course
our world champion and what a clash he
will have today against Wesley soy you
see how tight this matchup is two wins
two losses and 18 draws and let's not
forget dingley Ren is coming off his
first loss as a world champion against
alireza firuja that was a very difficult
moment but we know he can definitely
bounce back he's shown his resilience
time and time again most recently at the
world championship match against
he was a behind trailing by a point
quite a few times and always he was able
to bounce back he's done that so many
times in important events and I'm sure
he will be trying to emulate those type
of feelings in today's matchup against
Wesley so Wesley is such a difficult
player to crack though he's so so solid
and if you try too hard you will be
facing consequences and we've seen what
happened to Ali Reza earlier in the
tournament speaking of Ali Reza he is
definitely one of the hottest commodity
on the market in this tournament right
now after his victory against uh dangly
Wren but today he will be facing that
leader of the tournament Fabiano caruana
and Fabi has been having a blast this
tournament just getting his opening
preparation almost every single day with
the black PCS he doesn't really have any
problems equalizing and with the white
pieces we know how much pressure he can
put on you and this is exactly what
alireza will be feeling today Fabiano
with the white pieces I alibraza with
the black pieces that is going to be a
matchup that I'm having my eyes on guys
what do you have your eyes on well thank
you Christian for that setup in fact
Nasi lay the table for our viewers and
tell them what they can expect in
today's pairings let's start it from the
top right let's take a look at our
matchups today we have mvl plain wrapper
very very nice Richard he is one of the
trailing players uh looking I'm looking
in uh Dia kaganskiri both players
looking to win there being clearly ran
against Wesley so
five hour later against feroza it gets
bigger and bigger and nepomishi again
Studio again both players needing a
victory it looks like we've got a
fighting day of Chess ahead of us and
what are they fighting for right they're
playing for a lot of money they price
Fund in this tournament is 350 000 very
nice and the first place winner is going
to get one hundred thousand dollars
second place 65 000 and third forty
eight thousand very nice prize fund all
the way down to tenth and final Place
everybody gets a good prize and of
course it's about the grand Chester of
points and getting as many as you can if
you win clear first you get a bonus you
get 13 Grand Chester points the player
with the most grand chess tour points at
the end of the tour gets an additional
bonus of 100
000 in I believe 1.2 million the entire
Grand Chester uh tournament prizes and
bonus points as we see dingler in taking
a seat with the white pieces and I have
to say he was my pick to win the
tournament but his play especially with
white is leaving kind of a sour taste
it's not getting any I think he has a
new haircut
getting very refreshed
let's see if it helps though not not a
Samson uh type of thing going on but
there he takes a seat as uh all the
players are getting started I don't have
a a cheat sheet to tell you who's going
to be making the ceremonial opening uh
first move but we've had football
players we've had fencers we've had Coos
and CEOs uh who's coming up well it'll
be a mystery of course we've had a Gary
casparo make most a few times yeah but
we don't have we know who he is
bar anything in the first five rounds of
the players that has really stood out in
your mind
um definitely Fabiano's opening
preparation was very impressive Yasser
so far especially when putting a lot of
pressure with the white pieces so I'm
very excited to see the matchup today
against alireza all right here we go
this is Gabrielle the Prescott he's the
vice president of the super bet
Foundation our namesake sponsorship
sponsor for the superbed and he chooses
C4 very very wise man the English
opening one CTC four practice
around
the start of being in just a few moment
Bobby takes back C4 then leave it on the
board
and we have natural against Dura today
he is hoping to come back after two
losses in a row exactly back-to-back
losses I can tell you it only happened
to me once in my entire career but I
once lost three games in a row and I
thought the rules of physics had changed
the rules of Chess has changed I mean my
world was completely rocked two out of
the three games as well so it was like
really really beautiful when you when
you're in nepo's class of 2800 you know
losing a game hurts really really badly
back-to-back losses wow that just is
such a rare thing
for such a very very strong player we'll
see how he fights back
they say the rule is trying to make a
draw right yes exactly stop stop the
bleeding make try to make a draw and
just adjust after that yeah
yeah it happened to me also once in my
career that I lost three in a row and my
goals was just to stop
losing streak right you mentioned VAR
that you're impressed by Fabi with this
handling in the openings especially with
the white pieces to get today is a huge
day he's playing the highest seed or yes
and he has a good record against alirez
so he's got three wins and just one loss
against him how is he going to bring the
pressure today will it be E4 will it be
D4 I am exp well it's hard to tell Fabi
can play both but uh you know yeah I'm
thinking maybe ethos and I will add that
ferrush I won two games in a row yes yes
he's on fire exactly exactly uh wow one
man's fortunes nepos are going down
another is rising and remember uh Ali
razor his last classical event the
singfield cup many many months ago he
started with a loss against Wesley so
and he is bouncing back and guess what
guys if you have wow C4 why did he take
the move back yeah exactly well so so so
so farouza would know in English
and maybe slav well that's exactly what
she said now C7 C6 is an invitation to
Tango in the Karo Khan I was gonna say
Bobby can play E4 right
how do we say Knight of three so it's
most likely going to be the slap defense
yes now farusha played this I believe
with Duda that was the bishop no it was
with dioc pardon me it was and it was a
game that he won against the arc
outplaying him with Bishop F5 and Bishop
takes D3 G2 G3 against the slav move
order is this an invitation to try to
win the pawn absolutely yeah you can
take the yes you can take the pawn and
it leads to some sharp lines yes sir
after Bishop G2 castle and oftentimes
you see the move Knight A3 plate trying
to recapture the pawn with a knight and
the black needs to try to make it more
difficult because if you just if you
just allow the capture then white will
have also the control of the center
after like D4 okay so D take C4 did you
did you say Knight A3 right away or
Bishop Bishop G2 First bishop G2 first I
think Knight F6 right castles and uh
actually you can also play here F5 for
example if you want to develop the
bishop first well I'm wondering okay I
really want to play something that will
keep the pawn in my pocket
so uh how
which line will give me the best chance
of retaining the pawn so if I play B5
right away they're looking at a
potential A4 right yes so I need to do
something
that just I want to be able to meet
Knight A3 with I think we have please so
subjunation
whoa G7 G6 that's almost
Vichy Anand like I remember in his match
with um Magnus Knight eth where he did
this G3
G6 Queen A4
I think it will actually transpose to
classical Catalan after d takes C4 which
we already have on the board yes C4 if
Fabi decides to push D4 it in near
future in the near future then we have
Catalan would take C4 and C6
sometimes the transpositions nasia is so
weird I I I I think of it as a grunfeld
because your Bishop is on G7
Catalan yeah I mean okay I mean VAR will
tell us where we stand in about four
moves time and tell us what the name of
the opening is going to be as we
transpose into and we do have D4 by the
way on the board too
so uh are they transposing into a
groomfeld or a Catalan or a king's video
what do we got uh we got a it's called a
ready opening of course
it resembles the the groomfeld defense
yeah uh the structure here and so a lot
of games I see here not so many games
actually with this movie that we see
Bishop E6 is one of the main options try
to attack the queen we see this often
happening uh in this opening
um like let's say Bishop E6 yes and
Tempo yeah there was a game of yuyangi
and ding Loren here that ended in a draw
so in 2017 so you can play two options
you have Queen C2 or queen A4 let's say
queen C2
and actually taking the pawn on D4 it is
a possibility it doesn't look very
natural to give up the Dark Soul Bishop
but you can play this move Bishop takes
D4 but white will have a compensation
after let's say capturing Queen D4 and
Bishop G2 but the dingler and decided to
play the move
Queen A4
yes to keep an eye on the uh on D4 sorry
uh Fabiano played Queen A4 and now
oh this is actually the game position
yeah this is a game position yeah we
have the moves now so Queen A4 played
and um
let's see not not so many games played
not so many games played in this
position and uh Bishop D5 is a
possibility to put pressure on F3 uh
another option is just to develop Knight
D7 to try to play Knight B6
um Knight C3 for example
and like like if you play Knight B6 then
white will Retreat only one and uh White
has the control of the center after
Bishop G2 castle if it's possible will
also play the move E4 not not easy to
play with black it's uh needs black
needs to find a good move here to try to
maybe uh pressure in the center but at
the moment it looks like white might
have a slightly better position here
wonderful looking around the board
around the stage pardon me
I do see
a Mainline winner were French defense in
the game between mvl and Richie Rapport
now the French is a rare bird to begin
with but the early h4h5 as played by mvl
also is a very rare way a way of meeting
the winner okay let's first Richie has
been playing French defense in this
tournament so mvl for sure prepared this
line exactly
we just remind everybody that in the
game between nepo and Richie from this
tournament Knight D2 was essayed and
Richie got a pretty decent position out
of the opening and indeed he was
pressing in a game that was a
hard-fought draw Knight C3 the mainline
continuation Bishop B4 the steinist
defensive Knight F6 is also the main
alternative exactly in this position the
bishop B4 I want to say is the most
combative
way of continuing and with the move E4
E5 Bobby Fischer opined that this is
just killing the French defense that
white has this great bind in the center
this cramping position furthermore the
queen can easily drop in on G7 with a
move Queen G4 and they're very
well-known bad Bishop on C8 exactly the
French Bishop C5 A3 Bishop takes c3b B
Tech c397 a lot of players do like a
move order with Queen C7 which in some
cases it looks a little funny what's the
idea behind Queen C7 to meet the move
Queen G4 with sometimes this move F6 and
the queen nicely protects G7 but Knight
E7 is the most traditional move order
and here Knight F3 I think is by far the
most popular move order H2 H4 has been
S8 gosh thousands of times I'm familiar
with it but Knight F3 I think is
everybody's preference pardon me Queen
C7 this sets up an idea of capturing
capturing and queen C3 check it's not so
easy to think and against that check
uh but let me pause my insights for just
a moment and jump to Bucharest Christian
with a special guest
thank you Yasser yes we are here indeed
with Gabrielle petrescu the vice
president of the Superbad Foundation
Gabrielle first of all welcome to the
show tell us a bit about your first uh
thank you very much ideas about the
organization of uh this event how do you
enjoy it uh so I enjoyed very much I
mean I I came to the foundation
from the very beginning in 2019 when we
we set up the foundation and it was uh
so wonderful that from the from the
start we uh we have been involved in the
granches tour from the very beginning so
and for years in a row uh it was a it
was a great
experience the super PATH foundation has
a lot of initiative with youth tell us a
bit about the Hyundai songs yeah so we
have a lot of initiatives about youth we
are
sustaining grants in all sorts of
disciplines and Sports in education we
have two major same projects that we
have been developing in the in the past
years it's go scholarships that is
helping
the youth from 14 to 18 years old in in
getting performance in sports and the
other Project important project that we
are funding is the the Gambit the
step-by-step Center for education is um
is supporting this uh this project this
initiative and we are sponsor we are
funding it as a matter of fact and some
of these kids have actually had the
privilege of chatting with one Gary
Casper of not many days ago tell us a
bit about that indeed it was a very very
interesting meeting that that the
children from step-by-step Center as
well as the go scholarships had with
Gary Kasper they had one hour meeting
and they were really challenging Gary
Casper of uh with a lot of questions and
what I like the most was the fact that
they were asking questions about how he
behaved when he was young as they are
now and uh that that triggered some
emotions this is how I felt it uh on on
Mr casparov's side and it was um it was
pretty interesting and also a lot to
learn about how to deal with uh how to
cope with losing a game and this was
this was a question from them how do you
cope with losing and then it was of
course another question how do you cope
with when you win and that was a
wonderful thing no absolutely and to be
able to be so intimate with Gary
Kasparov one of the greatest chess
players of all time he's just an
incredible opportunity that you guys are
offering this young generation and you
guys are working with the cast
professors Foundation yes in schools as
well here in Romania yes uh also with um
with the support of the step-by-step
Center we we managed to translate the
the books that have been published by
the Casper Foundation it's called step
by step learning chess step by step and
there are three manuals one is for
kindergarten so we we start from Early
Childhood let's say
the other is for children in the primary
school primary school and then there is
also a big manual for teachers in order
to learn how to use chess not only in
how to play chess but also how to use
chess as a way of life as a way of
learning other disciplines that are not
necessarily related to sports or to the
chess itself but and this is I think
maybe the most important of all I think
you guys have a great system taking this
young minds from the early stages and
taking them all the way to University
the college level and the professional
level of of course congratulations and
thank you very much for everything
you're doing thank you it was a pleasure
guys back to you thank you Christian I
was reminded during that interview you
know Gary being asked how do you cope
with a loss how do you cope with a win
and uh Magnus Carlson the depressed
conference in Norway wanted a little
Norwegian boy saying you know like when
did you learn to stop crying after a
loss and Magnus looked at the little boy
and said what makes you think I learned
to stop crying it's very very sweet
um wow VAR I am stunned by the move uh
about that mvl just made in his game
with Richie Rapport
you are a long time French player and I
think this is a very very unusual moment
to play the move F2 F4
first of all is that theory with and if
it is I'm shocked but did do you find
this move stunning are you familiar with
this move yes this move is actually a
little bit surprising and I was told
it's a novelty actually never played
before and the idea is try to of course
expand at some point with the you're
gonna need them with G4 here to play the
move F5 if you're ever gonna be able to
play that move but the move is a little
bit surprising because it's not helping
with the development and also weakening
some of the squares in White's position
but I think mvl definitely analyzed this
position I want to go uh back a few
moves and show another idea potentially
black can try to do here which whenever
I play this positions this was my main
idea to try to do as block here so in
this position he played the the move uh
Knight C6 here I really like this plan
with B6 because I really want to play
that movie Space six here to try to get
rid of the bishop of course there's some
problems with this move as well in
particular there is always a move like
Queen G4 here targeting the pawn on G7
and oftentimes you have to play the move
can get Faith here because there is no
any other good way to protect this so
you put the King on f8 and then you play
the movie Space six I had a lot of games
played like this with black some good
wins some losses as well here but I
really want to see this movie Space six
plate here to get rid of the bishop
however black didn't play the movie six
played Knight
B C6 here and I see some games played in
this in the database Lego hit a game
with the white pieces here after this
move and here white can play Rook H3 for
example Queen G4 Knight F3 but no one no
one played this move F4
so the idea is to try to get the Knight
on F3 and try to prepare this move F5
which of course it's not going to be
easy to play but now we see report is
already thinking and then VL you know he
hasn't spent any time yet so what are
the Alternatives here for black here
well the most immediate move that comes
to my mind the most obvious move is
Knight F5
sure I want to go I want to take
advantage of the fact that the pawn is
on F4 because G3 is a weak Square
right nine F5 I think and it could take
on D4
absolutely Knight F5 move I think is
going to be met by this move Knight E2
because it's covering the G3 Square
exactly which I think is black is
something that you want to provoke it's
not like the Knight on E2 is really
great shakes so for example B6 just as
you suggested a moment ago B6 yeah then
we will see the G4 plate gotta go back
gotta go back and now if black man has
to play Bishop A6 will be very very
happy that that's my agenda so that's
why white will play this move Knight to
G3 okay opening up the diagonal for the
bishop and also preventing the move
Bishop basics
and Knight on G3 also will help with the
potential F5 uh push a little bit later
so my question to
ensure the French player
play White uh it's it's hard to see
where you will Castle here it's probably
going to keep the king in the middle for
a while but sometimes you can Castle uh
long here maybe even put the king castle
short and put a king on H2 but really uh
depends how things will develop at the
moment there is no immediate danger for
white uh to Castle here it's more like
try to complete the development with
Bishop B3 Bishop B3 this position I will
be a little bit uncomfortable guys
because I see a lot of space Advantage
for white and not clear how black is
going to continue so that's why maybe
instead of the move Knight F5 yeah
unfortunately this 92 is a really good
move against Knight F5 there might be
some other options for example engine
likes this move F6 to try to create some
control play while a white is not very
well developed at all so try to open up
the position so this is one idea another
option is just to play Bishop D7 then
you're getting ready to play long Castle
but once again he really wants to play
this move F6 here to create some
Dynamics in the center and open up the f
file potentially
all right well keep an eye on that as we
look at the head-to-head matchups
between these two players f
of their 11 games pretty decisive number
in favor of MBL in terms of classical
chess form wins
exactly and with white f2f4 novelty uh I
mean it feels like an overreach but
black is going to have to find a way of
punishing it at the board it's not so
easy
facing a novelty that this could be if
this is a good move
it would really rewrite a lot of the
winner were theory in my mind I I I
always thought that white was going to
shy away from this move and oftentimes
you know you go Rook H3 Rook G3 and not
F4 G4 F5 uh okay well keep an eye on
that as I see that uh for a first time
we've kind of have I know hi dorf hello
I mean nice to see you again old friend
an open night or uh in the game between
uh baghdan Daniel dayak and Anish Gary
and
well a lot of players when they're
facing the night off these days they're
not going for the super ultra sharp
lines with Bishop G5 but more or less
trying to play a positional line with
Bishop E2 inviting a chevanigan with E7
E6 or E7 E5 always thought of this as a
bowl of slavsky
night or do you have experience with
this slide yes uh when I was studying
Bobby Fisher's games I loved the way he
played neither so neither was actually
my first opening before I started
playing caracon before he became super
solid yeah like what happened you didn't
have a good enough experiences with the
Knight arm no I did actually most of my
wins are from Niger maybe I should go
back to it so what happened I mean again
I had a a bad coaching advice as a give
up the night or if you're winning too
many games and stuff there let's make
more draws exactly Bishop E7 castles
castles Bishop E3 Bishop E6 rookie one
okay a little bit off the beaten path
eight seven eight six six I mean I think
Knight D7 is the main mode Everybody
Plays Knight bd7 yeah like A4 Rook C8
right tons and tons of games uh from
this move order h7h6 when the bishop is
already developed to E3 is a little bit
strange because it's sort of like I'm
worried I want to stop Bishop G5 well
I've already moved to E3 H7 H6 Bishop F3
well a clear indication of what Daniel
wants he he's defending the pawn on e4
so that he can make the move Knight seat
the jump Knight C3 to D5 possible
and it's funny it's like we could
transpose almost like from a night off
into a svishnikov or at least a
sashnikov looking furniture yes
physician right where I get to play A4
or A5 or
playing for the queen side majority well
keep an eye on this one VAR over to you
and what games have caught your eye
early in round six uh I wanted to
mention something about this game
because H6 move is actually a very rare
move as you mentioned ibd7 is the main
move in particular there are only like
three games in my database and one game
is actually played by Anish giri against
nepo from 2022 so he's actually he had a
game like this and there's a good chance
that the ACT actually looked at that
game and prepared something so in this
position that they have right now after
H6 in that game mentioned Nepal Nepal
won with the white pieces he played the
move Queen
so he played Queen D2 and after Knight
C6 he managed to win the game but in
this position when they act played the
move Bishop F3
which is which is very rare now I see a
couple of more games in this in this
position played and I think we will see
the move Knight bd7 here
to bring the Knight and a couple of more
moves to see how the game can develop
here after A4
Rook C8
and perhaps A5 could be played to try to
fix the structure here and uh very very
unclear position Rook C4 is a
possibility here to put some pressure
you can also maybe play Queen B8 double
up the Rooks on a C file sometimes we
can even consider some sacrifices on C3
if we can win the E4 Pawn here so so
still it's interesting position but
definitely Anish is uh very well
prepared because he had a game like this
last year against Nepal but let's take a
look at another game here
let's see this this game in particular
this before move is is our store is a
new move here Yu Yang Yi and dingly Wren
played this game and it was Queen C8
played in that game by white but Fabi
played the move B B4 here
of course you cannot capture the pawn
back because you're just gonna be mated
after Queen C8 so now after this move
black actually has a few options Queen
d8 is the best move to retreat and
control the ca Square you can also play
the move D3 if you like to deflect the
queen but white will play Queen takes D3
now
and if you play Queen takes before it's
a little bit dangerous because the king
is still in the middle of the board
white can try to gain a Tempo by Bishop
A3 and play for quick E4 so there is
some danger in in this line for black so
the best option would be to try to go
back Queen d8
and now Bishop B2
white has a little bit of leading
development now wants to recapture on D4
so you have you have few different ways
to continue here there is a knight H
final which I think gonna be hard to
play this move doesn't look natural at
all here but it's just specifically
against the move Bishop D4 because now
if you play Bishop D4 after the
recapture
you take back Bishop takes G2 and you
have a Knight hanging on D4 so Knight H5
would be a move to try to hang on to
this Pawn on D4 but also if you just
want to play a solid game you can just
Castle so I think something like this is
very likely to be played and queen d8 is
already on the board and if you play
Bishop D4 Knight C6 I don't see too many
problems here for alireza here
wow but the preparation of Fabi uh
you're playing an English ready opening
and then coming out with B4 shows that
he's got Novelties prepared in just
about every thing I don't know how he
does it he must be very very hard worker
indeed
but as we get into our broadcast today I
just want to say to everybody please we
welcome you to join our conversation
stump our panel tell us your tweets and
how do they get get in contact with is
messy right you can send us tweets using
super bad chess classic or you can tag
grantchester and you can also send us
questions via YouTube or tweet channels
on St Louis chess club
great and again we really enjoy the
tweets that you have sent us thus far
some very very challenging ones indeed
by the way Richie against F2 F4 he spent
a little bit of time but he did come up
with Queen
A5
and that is a bit of a challenge to the
pawn move to F2 F4 by the way
so if Bishop D2 yes I'm a pawn Grabber
so Bishop to D2 so very often times
in this winner were Pawn structure black
plays the move C5 C4
he simply shuts down the Queen's side
and he says specifically to this bishop
on F1
you're not in the game I'm never gonna
let you play I'm gonna play C4
oftentimes when black does make that
move C4 white retort is to play A4 and
Bishop A3 and say you shut down my light
Square Bishop but I've got a dark Square
Bishop that's going to hurt you the idea
behind them of Queen A5 is actually to
provoke to move Bishop to D2 now there's
two approaches that black can take one
approach is simply to say I'm going to
shut you down just like I told you a
moment ago I'm going to play the move C5
C4 and uh your Bishop's not getting to
A3 anytime soon the other approach that
black can make is actually to say VAR
you're right trading the light squared
Bishops is a brilliant idea why don't we
do it why don't we go for it we'll play
a move like B7 B six with the idea of
playing Bishop A6 now the fact that
black has made the stuttercept queen d8
to C7 to A5
might be meaningful in the sense that
white has played the move f2f4 it could
be argued the move's not very good but
Queen A5 can I suggestion yes Bishop
grab the pawn on A3 because I don't see
how Queen would be trapped a brilliant
question I mean a brilliant question yes
it does invite a uh a repetition but
that is always considered a success for
black uh so Queen takes A3 I'm assuming
white is going to say congratulations
you've won the pawn let's see how
um you you still have to develop right I
mean Bishop D7 is walking into Rook
takes I don't think you want to put your
king under this duress so you still have
to decide how you want to complete your
development do you want to go B6 Queen
will have to go back maybe right okay
queen that always does kind of invite C4
and I'm opening up the position for my
two Bishops maybe I'll just
continue like I sacrificed upon big deal
uh that pawn on A3 isn't bothering me it
really does bother you that I'm just
saying big deal I'm trying to put a
brave face on
um it takes some time by the way if you
do go back you're also inviting Rook B5
I'm a pond Grabber so I would consider
this at least you know like can I win my
Pawn back
so yeah Queen takes A3 it's not like you
win the best Pawn on Earth but it's a
palm it's considered uh your Take On The
Move Queen A5 VAR was that the I know
the engine wanted to play F7 F6 you
mentioned it a number of times that was
what the engine wanted to do
as a human being do you like to move
Queen A5
um I don't like the idea that much I
would like to see it like more like a
development Bishop D7 long Castle F6
that's the plan I would prefer here
right specifically here actually if you
win that pawn on A3 you're gonna lose a
lot of time right and that's gonna allow
white to actually get all the
development and potentially already get
ready to play the smooth G4 F5 so the
move B6 I like a lot in this position
just because I always want to play
Bishop basics in this position right but
there are some problems with this move
here I will show you specifically if you
try to play for that plan here so B6 if
you try here and actually white has a
very strong move here but it's not easy
to spot this move here and that move is
actually a force whoa that's a surprise
move the point is now you don't have the
move Bishop A6
because if you play that I have to move
C4 attacking your queen and if you
capture on A4
your queen is now trapped right so
that's the main idea of this move A4
enter you can play the move C4 which is
the best move here but in this case now
you're not even getting the a pawn I can
actually play the move Rook A1
and as you mentioned later on in the
game I have this plan Bishop C1 Bishop
B3 to bring this bishop to the diagonal
this is actually a very strong plan uh
of course you have to do this when the
C3 Pawn is protected here so actually
this position white is clearly better
now
here so I think
after Bishop B2 here uh it's funny but
the engine says Queen C7 is the best one
we're probably not going to see that
um if let's say you take the pawn on A3
because you know perhaps you went there
to win the spawn so white can continue
here with Rook A1 immediately as one
option
Queen B2 can can repeat that's that's
one option to repeat or just simply play
the move Knight F3 first
and let's say you go back Queen B6 you
win the pawn and now you're just gonna
spend time to go back Rook B1 here
attacking the queen
and let's see here Queen C7
and here actually white can capture the
panel on C5 here because at some point
the Knight will be able to go to D4 here
and Knight on D4 will have some options
even Knight B5 Knight D6 and most
important thing about taking here when
you play Bishop D3 you no longer have to
worry about the move C4 so this position
is unclear here it's I think uh uh it's
roughly equal here but again Castle link
into this potential G4 G5 it seems a
little bit risky but uh you also have
this F6 move that could be played to try
to open up the position so this is one
way black can play and I think this
position is okay another option is to
play b6a to try to get rid of the spawn
and after caption B6 once again we have
this bishop A6 idea to try to trade the
bishop this plan is very important
because without this distribution it's
going to be very hard to attack for
white here so that's why we see the move
Queen E2 played specifically try to
prevent that from happening
um the bishop A6 and here white black
can try to prepare for example Rook A4
activate the Rook on a four track maybe
play Queen A7 and Bishop Basics once
again to try to exchange the light
Square Vision this position is actually
unclear I think black is okay here thank
you VAR we saw a nice little picture
there of mvl making the move Bishop D2
and continuing I like to turn our
attention to the world champion ding
Loren versus Wesley so and I uh you know
as an English player it always warms my
heart to see the English and we were in
a round where twice yeah we see the
English opening uh one C4 by ding Knight
F6 Wesley played E5 E2 E3 Bishop B4 do
you prefer G3 yes okay I'm a G3 player
myself on when I'm on the white side but
I have played E3 with Queen C2 as well
Knight ge2 castles a2a3 give me the two
Bishops please no you can't have them
okay when you've played the move bishop
f8 and all the way back to E7 a little
bit costing time but you're also
permitting the move d2d4 which ding
plays captures now uh you might think to
yourself oh this is easy automatically I
want to play Knight takes D4 my knight
on E2 is not a very attractive looking
piece it stands in the way of my Bishop
what could be more natural than Knight
takes D4 in fact it's not that great a
move as I'll explain in just a moment
um what
happens is if you play Knight takes D4
you're losing control of the square d75
you're using losing control of the
square D5 and you're inviting D5 and a
pretty easy equality conversely with the
pawn on C4 the Knight on C3 you're
controlling the square D5 Queen takes D4
on the other hand you're ready to bring
your knight to F4 stepping out of the
way of the bishop and controlling the
square D5 if I can provoke black to play
D7 D6 I'll make the argument not
necessarily that I'll prove my point but
I'll make the argument that I'll have a
space Advantage as white knight A6
reminding white that hey wait a minute
you know there is a weak Square I'm not
an English player from either side
really but Knight A6 is that a typical
move definitely it is one of the
problems I think for a lot of players is
the very natural movement 8 C6 Queen D1
you might think to yourself well I'm
centralizing my knight what could be
more sweet than that 95 Knight F4 and
the strange part is you take a picture
of the night and you go okay look at me
aren't I beautiful I'm in the center of
the board but it doesn't hit anything
the pawn on C4 is easily defended by the
bishop on F1 and white will in the near
future develop his bishop and it's sort
of like long term I've got a plan I've
got an outpost long term for black not
easy so good looking night but how
useful is it Knight A6 on the other hand
wow well the Knight could easily play to
C5 sometimes
uh the Knight can jump on a good day to
the E4 Square rookie eight in Bishop f8
let's see how the game unfold for
unfolded now C7 C6 that's perhaps the
most direct way that black can play if
black is able to as we've seen before
play the move d75 he'll make an easy
equality uh and white will it it's funny
sometimes the Strategic battle
determines everything whoever wins
control over the D5 Square either white
will have an advantage positional
advantage or black will equalize it's
really that's uh simple as or other
times a factor it's always interesting
to see who's ahead or behind that time
seems a little bit better prepared maybe
because he has one hour and 21 minutes
okay so he's been playing pretty quickly
yes and I think has one hour and 12
minutes and he's been playing slowly in
quite a number of games and again and
I'm a little bit worried From ding's
perspective he's played White
will this be his fourth out of sixth
game where he started with two whites
yes
so and he hasn't done much with the
white pieces he's been ineffective but
okay we'll keep an eye on this one VAR
what king are you looking at
I'm looking at the game of Jan against
Duda and the first thing I notice is the
clock 135 for Wow versus almost one hour
for Duda and already over 30 minute
advantage on the clock here and uh this
was a Petra of Defense the Russian game
here and the surprise came here right
around here on the Move Queen B3 here
this position actually has been played
about uh 37 times here and uh White
tried many different ideas H4 was tried
to played before 93 rookie two but Queen
B3 is actually very rare here
so only we see uh two games played in
this position and was 2017 both games
are played by a Russian Grandmaster so
uh so the point of this move is just to
put pressure on B7 and also you're
stopping the move Knight before
immediately Duda started to think here
and he played the move Knight C7
and young played 93 and after a long
think now Duda play the move Queen C8
here
other Alternatives here are there is a
move G6 the idea is to try to control
the F5 Square because at some point you
need to watch out for ideas such as
taking only six and perhaps playing the
move Knight F5 so let's take a look
after Queen C8 here white is a little
bit better according to the engines and
one idea comes to mind is to play rookie
2 and double up the Rooks there are no
tactics here even though the bishop
looks vulnerable only seven there is no
good Discovery here with the Knight to
attack because if you take only five for
example Knight will take back and will
protect the bishop also attack the
bishop on F4 so at the moment there is
no there are no tactics here involving
this unprotected Bishop here so rookie
two let's see how black can continue
here one option is to play rookie 8 to
bring the Rook into the game and also
protect the bishop then we have Rook ae1
double pulling up the Rooks
Bishop f8
and here white can play a few few
different ways you can play the move A4
to try to gain some space on this side
of the board also you can play the move
H4 it's funny you can play A4 and select
both moves are very interesting here H4
will be with idea to play H5 maybe at
some point if you could put a Pawn on H6
that would be great probably most likely
when the pawn reaches a trap it will be
stopped here by the move H6 here so H6
uh so so uh evaluation is actually a
little bit better for white here it's
like you know 0.5 perhaps C3 and it
seems a little bit more comfortable to
play for white now you also have the
option to bring the queen to C2 again at
some point capturing on D6 and putting
the Knight on F5
so slight Advantage for nepo
and their lifetime head-to-head matches
three wins in nepo's favor one loss and
five draws so Napo and is enjoying the
outing uh outings that they have with
one under the bar I gotta ask your
opinion because
um the ding lyron has just kind of
played just as Wesley and in your face
move C7 C6 I'm gonna play for D5 uh come
hell or high water and the move E3 E4
wow
um are we still in theory because again
the fight for D I mean it's it's black
everything yeah at least we provoke to
push D5 even more that's what I wanted
to ask is this still Theory and I mean
it basically ding is saying I'm going to
control the square D5
doesn't Wesley have to make a Gambit of
sorts here
um yeah he probably needs to do
something pretty quickly here we can
take a look at some of the best lines
only one game played in this position
yeah only one only one not that much
Theory here the game between two Russian
Grandmasters so the move E4 it's not the
top move that comes into mind if you
look at their engines but uh
there are two options you have here you
can play the move rookie 8 which is
logical to put the Rook on open file or
you can also play the smooth D5 okay
which actually makes sense because you
already castled and Viking is still in
the middle of the board of course this
is going to be a pawn sacrifice but
let's take a look how black is gonna be
able to achieve a compensation here so C
takes D5 right C takes D5
so here we have a few different options
but let's take a look at this move first
Knight F takes D5
you can play Knight everything's right
if you take back with a pawn yeah that's
logical
to keep the Knight on C3 to protect so
you have a few options but I think this
move is very natural Bishop F6
now you want to capture the Knight on C3
and pick up the pawn on D5
so here's
let's see if let's say you play Bishop
C4
trying to develop and protect this is
already a really bad move because they
should take C3
C3 and a rookie check
uh
and if you play the move Bishop E3 yeah
it looks like you're just about to
Castle you'll enjoy this nice Advantage
with two Bishops and extra and a pass
Pawn on D5 but now you see a beautiful
tactic okay three takes
Queen H4 check check in the king and
also pick up the bishop and after G3
Queen C4 black is simply winning so you
have to be careful and this is why we
always tell our students make sure you
get that development and Castle because
things like this can happen if your king
is in the middle of the board right well
thank you for that or definitely the
cold shower tactic good morning St Louis
once enjoyed the captaincy of
Grandmaster Nick defermian in an
Olympiad
and in the Istanbul I think it was 2000
and Nick before the match as you would
sit down with the team and say okay guys
remember develop your pieces
Castle early
stay ahead on the clock well thank you
Nick very good yes yes yes that's great
advice but I like that move D7 D5 and I
even saw a flirtation there the engine
had with G7 G5 at a certain moment and
sort of like okay so E3 E4 I want to say
that's a very ambitious looking move
um you're you're spending some time but
one one line you didn't look at VAR was
that after D5 C takes D5 C takes D5 and
you looked at capture and so forth was
E4 E5 a little bit more of a viable
alternative idea is to maybe just win
the two Bishops what would have happened
in case of E5 yeah let's take a look
yeah I was also uh looking because this
E5 is actually a typical idea oftentimes
when we see the D5 break cdcd E5 happens
a lot but I don't think white will be
able to achieve much Advent here but
let's take a look at the key lines here
so for example black has two options
here you can play both Knight G4 and
Knight D7 so I think they lead to a
pretty much the same thing here Knight
G4
a bishop E2 will be played because you
really need to catch up on the
development here right so if let's say
if you don't play Bishop video you just
take the pawn on D5 then actually this
is really bad yeah sir takes yeah Knight
takes Bishops six five and now you have
a problems on the F2 Pawn so white but
white is in serious trouble here so you
really need to play the move Bishop E2
here to try to catch up on the
development so Bishop B2 now attacking
the Knight on G4 Knight takes only five
and now you need to recapture the pawn
back so you take Knight
F takes D5 Knight takes D5
Knight takes D5 and here uh black has a
few options here you can play the move
Bishop D6 you can also Play Bishop C5
here and by looking at the position it's
pretty clear that white doesn't really
have anything here no you're not even
canceled the question is even if you
were Castle do you really have much
Advantage maybe in that case you can
play Bishop perform and have a little
bit of pressure but here right now your
priority is try to Castle here even if
you move if you play a move like before
this is going to run into a strong
response Bishop E6 now and now if you
take on C5 Bishop D5 and black is doing
really well there so yeah if you try to
just Castle here
to get the king to safety then black
will play Bishop B6 and absolutely no
problems in this position for white I
think this would be a time for black
yeah this would be a good time to try to
find a move like Bishop E3 try to
exchange some pieces and equalize it
again equalize the game right right
and uh just to remind everybody about
the standings and where these two
players are in standing probably comes
into round six with a half a point
cushion not so much look at that chasing
pack cool Right ferocia Wesley and
Richard are right behind him wow
yeah the thing is so surprising to see
down there and being a challenger and
Champion tied for seven
desperately needs a win guys if he wants
to do anything in history he really
needs to find a way to win a game and
get it going but we know he's a strong
finisher that's how he finished at the
top in a candidates tournament that's
how he came back in a world championship
match to win it on tie break so that's
one thing we know about doing that he
can uh play well at the end which is
extremely important
no question about it even though we paid
we we spent some time already on this
game I personally find it really
fascinating I love the strategical fight
that is going on between mvl and Richie
report when we left it last we saw the
move Queen A5 trying to provoke and
indeed provoking the move Bishop D2 D2
which was played and then this move that
we've spoken about in the past C5 C4
shutting down the queen side and just
saying okay uh I black have an advantage
on the queen side I haven't you white
have an advantage in the center and
thanks to that you can leverage it to a
king-site advance with G4 G5 but
your Bishop on D2 is really really
passive your Bishop on F1 is really
passive We Now understand that this
Bishop's best diagonal is the A3
diagonal what are you going to do about
it it's it's a strategic challenge that
Richie is saying to MBL and VL said well
first of all
let me just defend my Pawn on A3 and
even though it looks a little slow I may
play Queen B2 and Bishop C1 and A4 in
the future a general question
because again it's not my opening does
Queen exchange benefit white in this
kind of structure never never it's
better for black okay yeah black is
always looking to trade Queens the
problem is actually Black's Queen on A5
and sometimes Black's Queen on A4 is a
nice blocking piece but it's not really
the the the
um the the potential White really now we
understand it immediately why you want
the Queens on the board after a move
like castles immediately you understand
that White's potential the attacking
force of the queen thanks to G4 F5
White's really happy to have the Queens
on the board in principle the French
defense endings are not unfavorable
because of the pawn structure it's
always that like somehow White's Queen
ends up playing to G for you know
lurking it's similar to kerokan where if
yes when white pushes Pawn all the way
to H5 in a lot of end games black has an
advantage because of that pawn on age
precisely it's upon structure Advantage
now here the funny thing is black
doesn't really want to play the move B6
what black really wants to do is kind of
what VAR wanted to do black wants to
play Bishop D7 castles and in the very
near future play for the move f7s 6 the
problem is the desirable Bishop D7 runs
into Rook takes now the question that I
might ask myself is imagine I play
Bishop D7 that's one move castles that's
two moves long or short long okay King
B8 that's three moves and King A8 get my
king into the corner and I start
counting how many Tempe am I spending to
do that I don't like playing the move B6
funnily enough why
why don't I like playing B6 I need to
use that square in many cases the Knight
could easily
transit to the A4 Square attacking C3
and there the Knight can cramp whites so
I'm I find myself drawn to the move King
d8 wow okay so you're gonna make a Tempo
move Knight F3 of iron race Ultron to
King C7 so now it looks like hey wait
look I've just spent all of these moves
but you can imagine that if I go Rook C8
King B8
it might be the same thing like I could
just go I can't even need that right you
could just go Knight C8 Knight B6 from
here
uh from the very starting position I
mean once you're Kingston exactly it
saves you some time exactly Richie
didn't go for that he found him he he
did play the move B7 B6 and again I just
find myself really drawn to these gains
because I like these strategic fights
you know like uh and right now by the
way we don't know the result of a game
obviously but which side do you like do
you like the the space
space you like the space you like the
two Bishops you like the space but the
pawn structure doesn't bug you that much
yes it does okay right b7v6 can get in
G4 and expand even more on the king side
well guess what
from your ears to mvl's moves uh G4 uh
one of the reasons why black might play
in this fashion is because he might be
thinking I'll place my Bishop on A4 not
a knight but I'll place my Bishop on A4
and keep you Tethered to a C2 pawn and
also the dark Square Bishop is not
playing anytime this is very strange
that Quinn White's Queen has to defend
C2 and A3 right two pawns yeah
and let's uh jump to uh Bucharest and
bring Christian into the conversation
what's the view like from Bucharest
Christian
while the view is very uh tense uh yes
and especially in this game between
Fabiano and alireza and I just want to
give you guys a little bit of insight
into their personal history well Fabiano
is winning a lot of games against
alireza at the beginning of your career
and let's not forget alireza is only 19
years of age you sometimes have these
one or two players against whom you just
simply cannot play very well as you can
see three wins one loss and five draws
but a lot of those wins were played in
very important events I remember uh
Fabiano won with the white pieces in the
grand Swiss a couple of years ago that
was a qualification event for the
candidates in fact both of these players
qualified from that grand swiss but
Fabiano best in alireza in that
tournament then he bested him in the
candidates as well very important uh
games very important tournaments and
Fabiano seems to be getting the better
of alireza in each of at this event and
right now he's putting a lot of pressure
on him and it's a matchup of styles
right alireza seems to be very doing
very very well
um after the opening phase is finished
perhaps the opening phase just due to
the lack of experience that he has at 19
years of age he just didn't have enough
time to build that rock solid repertoire
that you see with most of these players
and Fabiano is definitely taking
advantage of that and let's take a look
at what happened in today's game Fabi
started with C4 you guys kind of
analyzed the majority of it but let's
try to understand where things went
wrong because I do think that right now
in the current position that we have on
the board Fabiano has a pretty
significant Edge in the position at
least a very pleasant Edge in the
position and C5 Ali Reza knew what he's
supposed to do he needs to strike in the
center as fast as possible lengthen the
action of the dark swear Bishop on G7
and just get some activity in the
position otherwise you're just slowly
slowly going to be rolled back that's
why you played Queen to A5 by the way to
support this idea of C5 as well
and now we have Castle
and this by the way has been played
yuyangi versus dimly ran from 2017 but
is the only game that I'm seeing in the
database and in that game c takes D4 was
the move as well the move that has been
played in this game and the move that I
think is the inaccuracy in the position
I believe Knight to C6 was perhaps
better but at the same time it's not an
easy move to make especially if you
don't know the theory for example if you
take on C5 now you go Castle as black
white ghost A3 slowly slowly trying to
connect those pawns maybe Rook to B1 I'm
two moves away from connecting those
pawns root to B1 because of course for
example
um if you play Rook to d8 and I go B4
you can just simply take on B4 and
mitochond A1 is going to be hanging
after eight takes before so you cannot
play b40 yet but you are two moves away
from that Rook to B1 follow it up with
B4 and then there's just going to be a
comfortable Pawn up for a black but what
for white excuse me but what black can
do is just simply Play Moves such as
Queen to B5 change the action of the
queen from the a file to the B and the
A6 F1 diagonal as well putting some
pressure on E2 the idea in this position
is that you have to stop white from
finishing his development on the queen
side if you manage to do that as uh
black then you're most likely going to
have enough resources to get either the
E2 Pawn back or the pawn on C5 back and
if you manage to do so and perhaps
exchange the Queens in the process as
well Knight to D7 Queen takes C5 things
of that nature then you're not simply
going to have any problems in the
position but you have to know all these
moves and by the way white has a lot of
options at this point and I'm sure
Fabiano most likely had some ideas about
what he's supposed to do E4 is one of
them Rook to B1 is another uh one of
them B4 in this position is another move
as well let's take a look at what
happened in the game c takes D4
and now B4 a very important move you
cannot take do not take home before
that's just Checkmate in uh one move you
guys probably already I saw this VAR
most likely pointed it out before Queen
to d8 Bishop to B2 and white is just
getting his pieces out with Tempo he's
just a step ahead in development and
that pawn on B4 is uh going to give him
a lot of Leverage on the queen side
because whenever a knight lands on C6
I'm going to always be able uh to annoy
it with the move a B5 as we are seeing
from the bird's eye view right now as
well and a few more instances and ideas
in this position after the move A5 most
likely we're going to see just a
solidifying move perhaps A3 you want to
keep the pawn on B4 it limits the action
of black species quite severely in the
position and I just simply don't see
Black's plan right now and White's plan
and fact is very easy first of all I
have this very annoying battery on the
long diagonal you can get away with
Knight to E8 but that's going to take
your knight all the way to a G7 right
and that's not a tremendous Square
Fortnight and I can just simply follow
it up with natural moves and this is
part of the problem for alireza as well
white has very natural moves in the
position Rook F to D1 I'm setting up
this cannon on the D file you have huge
problems with the bishop on D5 and if
you give it to me if you play Bishop
takes F3 which perhaps is the best move
in the position well thank you very much
now I have an open Center position my
Bishop on G2 is a laser on that long
diagonal it just feels like wise
position is much more comfortable to
play and these are the exact type of
positions that we've seen alireza fall
to the sharp sword of Fabiano time and
time again in their previous encounters
so this is why I'm slightly worried for
alireza definitely with the victory
Fabiano will be taking a commanding lead
in this event this is a crucial game for
the standings and potentially for the
whole event thank you Christian big
moments indeed as we prepare for our
break first of all before we go on break
we've got to ask what is happening at Q
Boutique our in-store shop here in St
Louis well here's your chance to get
this popular limited edition t-shirt
commemorating the World Chess Hall of
fame's Mind art experience 10 years of
Chess and culture in St Louis featuring
a drawing of the world's largest chess
piece and the World Chess Hall of Fame
building available as always only at
cubeboutique St louis.com please for all
your shopping chess shopping needs do
visit Q Boutique and as we go to break
we ask the players on the special
they interact or what do they think of
AI artificial intelligence here are
their answers
[Music]
as chess players we've had a symbiotic
relationship with computers for quite a
long time are you using the new
technology chat GPT all these new
artificial intelligence solutions that
we have right now
yeah we're just players use AI to change
I think it's an Open Secret yes and
neural network is basically a must for
today's Grandmaster it was Revolution
like some five years ago I think that
Alpha zero bits
back then in London that was very
unexpected and very big chance engine is
like I got I mean it cannot beaten and
here it comes some AI you know who a day
before didn't know which is rules and
just smashed smashed the stockfish so
after that I mean
everyone was really like
fascinated I guess by it and also was
looking for ways to improve their chess
yeah I mean for me personally like it's
Alpha zero and and just AI stuff is um
as a whole is of course it changed the
game of just the way we played compared
a few years ago when it came but I
believe it's just sort of a test Trace
if you build a company II version of
what's going to happen outside of Chess
in the real world and I believe since
chess is you know to me it's a very
important game but it's just a game
right there are much more serious issues
in the world so I believe chess is
showing the day I can come up with
serious unexplored ideas in a game that
people have been playing for for you
know ages AI can really be a game
changer it's still progressing a lot we
don't know after one or two year what
will happen but I'm sure that if we can
use it in a good way it can be
beneficial for chess and as it was for
instance a stockfish when it came out
everybody thought it would be dead the
chest but it also grow the chest so we
can learn more and we study more but I'm
very optimistic chess and AI together
it's a very good company combination
computer Thriller revolutionized the
game
um and so players as a player you need
to adjust be ready for
uh everything but at the same time I
think that computers can only really do
so much in the game because
as a player you can your brain can only
take so much you can only memorize so
many lines
so in that regarding chess has become
more difficult than the old days I
personally my opinion I don't think that
the computer can change the game as
radical some people I think it can but
I think you know people still play the
game uh there's obviously a lot more
Theory nowadays than before yeah the AI
has sort of
I started with chess pretty much
I think the big breakthrough was when
Alpha zero
was built and that that's also you know
gave confidence to our researchers
as I've heard to just you know to see
the potential and now building on that
there are so many tools already in the
making and I'm sure within the chest
within the chest World there are many
things you can utilize it for you can
definitely see um
potential in some sort of AI tutoring it
seems like it's liking you know power to
answer these specific questions and
for now and it seems like you know the
engines we have no stockfish with Alpha
zero when they when it came out they're
the best AIS that I know to answer these
specific questions so foreign
professionals and I suspect it won't be
anytime soon but I could be wrong yeah I
think I will try that
sometime it was and they will combine
Maybe
something else with the stockfish and a
little zero or something yeah and it
would be quite quite useful too but I
guess we are not at this point but you
know things are developing quickly
itself like we don't
like the language learning model doesn't
have
much relevance at the moment for chess
but still like we've seen the the
computer Revolution it continues like
computers are super super strong in
chess and and I think that we're going
to see that like across the board not
just in chess but in everyday life
technology is going to continue to uh to
to expand and
who knows what will happen I mean
hopefully more good things and bad
things well you never know but in terms
of Chess it's definitely changed the
game quite a lot
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to our live coverage of the
super bet chess classic from Romania
here are our standings after round five
Let's see we have in seouli Fabiano
caruana with three and a half points and
close the following firusha with Lisa
and Richard rapper with three points
absolutely and look at the match-ups
today the pairings have just been
incredible as number one and number two
rankings there it is on the fourth table
right the most exciting game between the
two leaders Carolina and perusa
absolutely but across the board so many
great fights including beings
MBL versus Richie and let's just jump
into all of the actions during the break
we're actually kind of laughing over
over the game between
um Daniel dayak and Anish Gary because
H7 H6 a little bit off the beaten path
Bishop F3 the most natural move for
White and the board and you know
prepping the move Knight D5 is Daniel
and then it was sort of like we we've
got a monitor problem you know Anish
Gary didn't move for 30 minutes 35 I
think 35 years it was like what you know
come on dude I mean everybody's
expecting you to prove you're the one
who played H7 H6 you know you just did
this marvelous chessable course on the
night or come on Anish
35 minutes was he's trying to remember
his prep or not eight six A5 and the
moment that move came on the board all
of our database went out you know like
this is a novelty in our I don't know
how many millions of games
a6a5 surprise a2a4 Knight A6 you would
ask me wait a minute is 986 a kind of a
reasonable move it's not something you
see very often in a night or if I must
actually saying id7 and sometimes Knight
C6 exactly but Knight A6 okay rookie two
B7 B6 and me immediately understand what
Anish wants to do he's he wants to take
control over the C5 Square play the move
Knight C5 and try to induce white to
capture
so that he can solve his backward Pawn
on uh D6 no no no no okay think about
this
I love it it's it's it's a very very
familiar pattern for me because I've
seen a lot of players use this Anatoly
harp off in quite a number of his games
have played this now it seems to our
eyes that the bishop on F3 was
exclusively preparing for the move
Knight D5 but because of Black's
peculiar play A5 B6 Knight A6 you really
are inviting me to change directions I
start to think I shouldn't be playing
Knight D5 I should be blasting away
against the D6 pawn and I want to put my
knight to
B5 so let's see what happened next Queen
B8 and that's kind of a Prelude to the
idea of like I'm ready to play Rook uh
Rook to d8 now Anatoly carpal if you'll
go back to his candidates World
Championship World Championship
candidates match with Juan Boris baskey
in such positions rerouted his Knight
right to C1 at night to E2 93 Knight F5
and Away you go another one of these
great complex strategic fights that I
love much like the MBL Richie Rapport
game VAR this this this game has a lot
of content what do you think of the
current position
absolutely yeah sir I also didn't like
the move A5 when Anish played after
spending 35 minutes also I'm surprised
too but that he didn't really analyze
the movies 50 it looked pretty natural
and typical move for this type of
positions the current position white is
better but the move that gives them the
most Advantage is not easy to find I
will show you now so it's actually the
move Knight C1 here
so because the Knight on B3 it's not
very well placed here as you can see all
the squares Knight wants to go are it's
covered now c5d4 so you really need to
improve this Knight and ideally you you
want to achieve a setup where you have
let's say this Knight on B5 then the
other night on C3 right so that way
you're threatening also to play Knight
D5 here so Knight C1 is the best move
and now uh let's say black plays Queen
B7
to connect the Rooks to bring this Rook
on C8 now you play the smooth Knight one
to E2
and Rook fd8
protecting the D6 plan and also of
course it's a dream for uh black to play
the smooth D5 at some point but it's
going to be extremely hard to do that
with the bishop on F3 and now we have an
option here to even play the move Knight
G3 now we see this long maneuver now
Knight on G2 now Knight F5 is a
possibility it's not easy to play the
move G6 because you have the H6 Pawn
hanging and that's what happens often
time when you play the move H6 it's very
hard to play G6 because you have the H6
Pawn hanging here so let's say Knight C5
bring the Knight and try to put pressure
only force and here's why it even has
this option to try to exchange this
Knight on F6 because after that you can
put the Knight on D5 and you're not
afraid of the capture because you can
recapture with the Rook here so for
example if you take here
Bishop takes
now if you're wondering why not take
only four in this line You're simply
losing an exchange after the move Bishop
F3 now we pick up the Rook on A8 and
also we have a b there is a B6 spawn
hanging as well here
so after Knight H5
which page five you have to bring the
Knight to D7
and again it's not a big Advantage but
it's pretty clear that white is doing
really well here we have a control of
the B5 Square D5 square and I really
like this for white and Bishop G4 is one
option here to try to exchange the
bishop only six
so at the moment the clock situation is
105 for deck is actually ahead on a
clock and another Anish has 50 50
minutes so I like this for white I think
white has a slightly better position
here
thank you for that for our game that's
underneath the radar but uh very very
important for both players or
tournaments uh is NEPA versus Duda now
when we left it it was one of those dry
petrol positions Russian Physicians that
we you know white is struggling to show
anything so let's turn our attention and
go away well things have been happening
as we turn our attention away in this
position VAR was explaining that the
open file rather like a magnet you'd
like is white to play rookie two and
Rook on A1 to E1 doubling on the open
files got to be reasonable will it bring
a big Advantage who knows
different approach by nepo he just took
the bull by all the horns captured the
Knight Bishop takes and said C4 look
I've already connected my Rooks your
Queen's a little bit Tethered on the
back rank to the B7 Pawn I as white want
to blow up the position
open the game so that my better
development my pieces will flood into
the position and I will win brilliantly
well that's his point let's take a look
at their time there's almost an hour
difference right in fact there was 135
at a certain moment maybe just before
Bishop takes dv6 Jan had a an hour and
35 minutes he started with an hour and
30 minutes so he had been playing a la
Tempo and how deep is his prep because
he played it very quickly now you are
saying an hour difference Nasi almost
it's like more than 50 minutes yes okay
c2c4 let's go I I I see a weakness if
you let me do it I'm going to capture
twice on D5 Bishop F4 here I think Duda
understood that if he captures Knight
takes at first blush you think oh
isolated Queen Pawn what's my problem
but the moment you see this position
Knight takes Rook takes rookie seven you
stop you go I mean wait a minute why
didn't I invite this Rook into my SEC
seventh Rank and I don't like this as
black which is why exactly in this
position you know D5 takes C4 looks like
an easy normal capture that it might
bring you unhappiness Bishop F4 takes
Bishop takes E3 that was the whole point
of the whole concept now why to sing
Bingo oh no this is not
what I signed up for now in this case
it's all the difference in the world The
Rook is not coming to E7 this is a Tempo
black has more than happy now here uh my
favorite in between moves yeah but wait
a minute aren't you exposing your king a
little bit here Bishop takes F2 check a
switch and Zug before I recapture on C6
King takes F2 takes and this is an
imbalance that is not common to a Petrov
now uh you know both players have trumps
that they can talk about bravely and
look aren't I great
yeah we exchanged F white F Pawn for
black C Pawn yes how how easy to do yeah
but but also then how do you make the
Judgment of who who benefits from the
trade I always think of Trades as you go
to a Marketplace and you say I have some
butter you have some bread let's make
this trade but then the idea is that
through each trade you're trying to get
an advantage you're trying to earn
something who has who has earned in this
imbalance who hasn't earned the most my
king is more exposed the structure for
black is compromise jump invar did Napa
make a good trade in the marketplace
uh he's very slightly better yeah sir
slightly better very slightly better
here by the way uh when Nepal played the
move C4 at that point do not spent
almost 35 minutes that's why he is so
much behind on a clock but he did find
the best move which was Bishop before as
you mentioned the line with detect C4
would just be very very bad for black so
the current position is very slightly
better for uh White here and I will show
you some lines here but I think with
accurate play Black shouldn't have too
many problems in particular you really
want to put that Knight on E6 in this
position because it will be well placed
protecting protecting against any
pressure on F7 and also applying
pressure to the only weakness in a wide
position is the D4 Pawn here so but you
need to find a good setup here and again
the clock is ticking and Duda needs to
figure out the correct setup here
otherwise he could be in trouble in
particular I think if the Queens come
after board here I think black's
position is more more vulnerable here
because there is a little bit of
weaknesses on the White's King so with
the Queen's on I think you will have
better chances here but let's take a
look what should black do in this
position here so first thing you need to
do here is to put the queen on B7
and the reason is you want to connect
your Rooks and immediately you're
attacking the pawn on B2 so this will
force the move B3
then you don't really want to put a
knight on D5 in this position because if
you do that then after Rook ac1 there
will just be pressure the Knight will be
very nice looking on the fire but not
doing too much here so I kind of like to
put the knife only six here to try to
have some pressure here
and now let's say
white plays Rook ac1
and here we can play Rook fd8 is one
option or Rook ac8 if we play Rook fd8
then we will enter into this line Queen
takes C6
Queen takes C6 Rook takes C6 Knight D4
capture Rook D4 and in this end game
it looks like white should be a little
bit better like if this pair of the
Rooks are off your Rook is only six then
you you're better but it's not so easy
because if you play the move rookie 7
here then I have the move Rook D2 now if
you move away I have Rook A2 if you go
back rookie two
just simply Rook D5
activating the rook and putting the pan
on A5 at some point Rook can go to F5 G6
and shouldn't be too many difficulties
here to hold this end game so that's why
in this position after Rook fd8
you can try to protect the pawn but
that's also not going to give you much
Advantage here because now you have the
option of playing simply okay see it
again you there's a pressure on C6 but
also as well on D4 here and after H6 I
don't see too many problems in this
position for black I think black should
be able to hold that's why I like this
Knight only six here to be more active
put pressure also some possibilities of
Knight F4 as well
thank you VAR and our producers have
been having a little bit of fun of their
own and they decided to take a look back
to go back two years on the grand chess
tour and compare uh the event in
Bucharest where it stood after the free
day and what happened next and here we
go
so after round five in the 2021
standings Shaq
Wesley we miss him in this tournament
yes we do and Sasha grishek we're all
tied for first with three out of five
what a pack of players and then Shaq
went on to win the event after the break
and in 2022 after five rounds of plight
we had Wesley Wesley look at that the
three and a half Lavon aronian mvl
baghdan Daniel dayak having a great
tournament in 2022 or on three points
but guess who went on to win the
tournament MBL uh and he was insured
second after
and then the current standings for us
today we have a new leader Fabiano
Carolina yeah but this is almost unfair
because Bobby is playing Ali Raza today
with the white pieces if he goes through
right now we think he has a a nice pull
uh no decisive Advantage but if if he
were to pull it off he'd be in Pole
Position by the way the scores are
almost identical to us what was it about
to say was that a was that an echo what
what happened there uh history uh
repeating itself but wow I mean the
fields are just incredible I just wanted
to jump back into and again remind
everybody we love it when you join the
conversation send us your tweets we'd
love uh being put on the spot and
telling you what we think about the
world and everything that's going on
um I'm referring to the game of mvl and
Richie for a second a small incremental
moves have been played
after Castle's long I like this move
very much by mvl the move Bishop H3 at
first it looks like Ugh like what is the
bishop doing there until you start to
realize well the bishop really doesn't
have that many good diagonals to begin
with it's not doing anything on the E2
diagonal the pawn on C4 blocks if you
put it on on G2 yeah but it's kind of on
the other hand the move Bishop H3 makes
perfect sense when you start to realize
that White's hole the play is tied to
the break F4 F5
Queen A4 that's a one of those little
post-up moves that I really like it
stops a3a4 means that this bishop is
contained puts a little pressure on C2
it's the Improvement yes the small
little improve improving move Queen B2
Rook V8 Bishop E3 G7 G6 and VAR when you
play the move F2 F4 is white I'm not
saying that mvl is prepared this precise
position but his expectation of getting
this type of position must have been in
this opening Laboratory
absolutely yeah this position is very
slightly better for white but I have to
tell you black has a very solid position
and there's only one thing he needs to
watch out here is the F5 brick in this
position because the queen side is
completely locked and I think mvl made a
slight inaccuracy here which is very
difficult to spot uh in this position
actually it's much better to have the
Knight on G3 so that's why engine was
recommending instead of the move Knight
F3 if he moves back to play the move 92
Knight G3 and there is a particular
reason why because G6 is a standard move
in this position to try to prevent the
move F5 and also at some point you want
to capture on H5 and try to put an iron
F5 but with the Knight on G3 you can
never do that because if you take on H5
Knight takes H5 move always going to be
extremely strong here exactly so now
after G6 actually black position is fine
here so I will show you some of the
lines here so again very solid position
for black no weaknesses and this F5 is
going to be very hard to play here and
and the move G6 is very strong now you
have this option to capture on H5 so you
have to actually do something maybe even
Bishop G2 to retreat to be able to
capture back with the Rook here and
black often times can even just sit in
this position and just wait and say okay
what is your next move what is your plan
here because if you take on G6 ft G6 at
some point black can consider the move
H5 and try to establish this very strong
Square for the Knight on F5 and once you
get this F5 Square this other Knight can
go to E7 this Knights are very well
placed on F5 and C6 defending each other
but if we go back a few moves here I
want to point out uh this idea as I
mentioned here all the way back here
right in this position if he had played
the move G4 here we go a couple of moves
it will be a similar position but Knight
is actually going to G3 and that is
going to make a big difference here
because let's say if you do the same
idea Knight G3 once the Knight is on G3
you already have enough pieces to
threaten this move F5 and if G6 is
played in this position you actually you
don't have anything to worry about here
because even the capture I have Knight
takes H5 you can even consider the move
Castle here and then simply tuck in the
King on H2 and then eventually play the
move F5 here the Knight on G3 is much
better than the Knight on F3 even the
Knight on H5 and that is the difference
here why in this position white doesn't
have that much of an advantage here
I have one question for you since it
looks like I'm learning a lot about
French today right
it's the idea to put the King on D2 okay
let's take a look Bishop E3 just a few
moves back well in fact the very last
move Bishop E3 Bishop E3
um what's the idea of behind that move
it's possible it's possible he wants to
play Candy 200 try to bring this Rook
into the game
um and now G6 played immediately uh I I
like I like the smooth G6 another idea I
see another with this move is maybe
potentially he wants to bring this
bishop to H4 at some point that would be
ideal plan and it's possible actually
that's what he was trying to do here
Play Bishop F2 Bishop because it
certainly would be an improvement to
have the bishop on H4 over on D2 here
where it's not really doing much so but
this move G6 is very concrete it's uh
it's not just sitting and defending
trying to get some Contra play here and
I've seen sometimes black even win this
kind of positions because uh definitely
White's position is overextended and
thinks if things open up there could be
some good squares to go to here but here
again the threat is to take so Bishop G2
is necessary and now this move uh you
can put you can even put this Rook on G8
because now you have some ideas to take
and pressure on G2 and if captures on G6
there is even option to take takes G6 it
doesn't look as good here but it's very
concrete you're putting pressure on G6
here
and if Bishop H3 played you play the
move F5 again you want to establish a
good Square for the Knight on F5 and if
there is a capture if you do an ampassan
there could be a little bit of danger at
some point because position is now
opening up there could be some potential
exchange sacrifice here so it's uh it's
not completely safe this position for
white okay thank you I feel a
disturbance in the force uh here uh VAR
uh speaking for the audience they're
crying out and they're saying why
did Richie play the move Rook on d8 to
f8 only to follow it up with the move G7
G6 isn't there a logic glitch there in
my mind you play the move Rook f8
because after Bishop E3 you want to play
F5 and or F6 not the move G6 G6 kind of
voluntarily weakens the square F6 and as
you were pointing out maybe on a good
day and whatever lands on F6 you're
going to be crying over the move G6 so
why didn't he follow up with F6 or F5
very good question Yasser but F6
actually often times even from my
experience of playing the French for a
very long time when the center is so
strong for white you try to play F6 you
have to be very careful because it can
really backfire one thing we have to
keep in mind here guys the white has the
pair of the Bishops so if we try to open
up the position that's gonna that's
going to benefit white here in
particular the F6 move in this position
is gonna give this Knight a very strong
Square on H4 and now we see this G6
square is going to be available in a lot
of these positions and if we we take on
E5
F takes if I now this bishop is going to
be opening up here and then at some
point some G5 ideas can come into play
here as well so Bishop E8 if we try to
secure the G6 Square then King goes on
D2 the move now let's see what's coming
exactly and this this I don't like it as
much because I feel like we have to do
something because if we play passively
Rook will come on F1 at some point G5
will come in that's why engine actually
wants to play this move G5 right to try
to remove this Knight if Knight goes
back on G2 then black doesn't have any
problems here so you always have to look
at this option take right Knight takes
G6 and here
you can maybe have a small Advantage if
you take on G6 but the key key move in
this position is this spectacular move
Knight F5 whoa that's nice that nowhere
yeah if Knight reaches the D6 where we
know the Knight on D6 is going to be a
big Advantage for white right and you
have to take
and now G takes F6 you have two
connected pass pounds now Bishop is open
you're probably gonna drop this H6 spawn
at some point if you play Knight H4
putting pressure on the pawn and also
threatening Knight and three white will
calmly play this move Rook B F1 and this
Knight doesn't have too many squares to
go to next thing white wants to play F6
it's a pretty big Advantage here for why
this position despite being down a piece
wow a brilliancy in the making fantastic
stuff thank you for that bar wow that
was
something special is Daniel diac finally
playing the tournament that he had hoped
to because he is putting the pressure on
on inish giri the first five rounds in
my opinion were disaster for the
Romanian project in Prodigy he was in
time trouble just about practically
every game he was on the back foot
everything was going against him if you
will but today he is putting together a
really wonderful game he did find that
whole maneuver Knight B3 to C1 to E2 and
really we were we were talking about hey
look if I can get this this is great B
fight takes Knight takes B5 Knight A4
keeping all the pieces on the board and
reminding black that hey wait a minute
you know there's a there's a square B6
this is not your happy night or after B5
I like this reaction yes uh not only and
I could possibly go to B6 but I think he
wants to push C4 yes B3 C4 taking a firm
grip over the D5 Square uh VAR was
mentioning a setup with white knight on
B5 and another White Knight on the E2
going to C3 and then you're just you
know sitting uh beautifully against this
backward Pawn on the half open file uh a
niche who drew if I'm not mistaken the
first five games yes yeah in a little
bit trouble let's jump to the game
between uh Ding and lerin and Wesley so
because again as we came on the show so
we said look at this Marquee matchup
when we left it Bishop E2 White's play a
little bit artificial upon on East they
didn't push D5 right away no he did not
this was a crucial moment he played in
fact the move rookie eight D5 it
certainly caught our attention what are
we natural Gambit players or something I
don't know why but we wanted to
sacrifice a fawn for Wesley Wesley says
not necessary rookie eight Bishop E2 and
you didn't get a chance to mention this
on air but you certainly mentioned it to
me in a discussion we were having you
were attracted to the move b7v5 and it
was sort of like hey check this out yes
yeah go play B5 Fawn on e4 is hanging I
want to take and uh Play Bishop A6 and
you were getting excited it's sort of
like hey wait a minute maybe Wesley is
for Choice Wesley was a little bit more
practical down to earth I don't know how
to put it play Queen E7 gifted me the
pawn
not exactly the move that you want to
make f2f3 have to yeah now that those
all those lines with D7 D5 start to look
a lot more attractive now that we've
provoked F2 F3 and we actually saw the
move Queen E5 we caught up to the
players and first impression is it feels
artificial yes yes I agree and I like
Queen E5 because you do Wesley wants to
play D5 without sacrifice in that pawn
yeah okay that that sounds good to me
too and he'll be ready
every time this whole series of captures
for Bishop okay it's time for white to
Castle shouldn't wait any longer I mean
yeah I mean how long can I wait okay
Castle no D5 and that's the equalizer is
it well maybe even because E2 is hanging
uh I prefer black already really well
yeah no I I'm I'm just thinking like
takes takes takes I'm already this
bishop C5 check on the board but there's
also this move I have two in between
moves Bishop F5 and Bishop C5 exactly
exactly I'm not liking what is happening
uh you know that again I mentioned a
while ago there was even this G5 this it
kind of flittered across the screen of
the chess engine here I can imagine B6
and Bishop C5 but the simplest Rook 88
uh I always white going to develop the
queen side exactly more like how is
white going to equalize help me out here
VAR uh after Queen E5
I castled because what am I supposed to
do uh dingler in
I said at the top of the show he's been
struggling with white he doesn't have
the advantage he's hoping for today
absolutely he's actually worse in this
position he stands worse yeah and he's
been spending over 25 minutes on this
last move Queen E5 is a very clever move
and I really like this move the move
that Nazi suggested would be if I was
also another very strong continuation
black might be even slightly better
there as well but Queen E5 is slightly
stronger again the main idea you want to
play the move D5 right so I think Dean
has to Castle here if he doesn't Castle
here I think he could be in big trouble
so I will show you the the moves now
after this move uh Queen E5 here so
Castle is necessary the other move is
Queen E3 but I find it very hard to play
this move the point of this movie is
actually that you want to put this
Knight on D3 here the Knight on F4 is
not really well placed in this position
and again that G5 move at some point you
have to calculate because you have no
good squares to go to you're gonna have
to go back to H3 so Queen E3 is a second
but after D5 the block is better there
too so most likely he will cancel here
she is also getting a little bit long on
time and now the move D5 comes in so C
takes D5 C takes D5 now threatening to
take only four so you have to play
Knight fd5 again there is also an option
like Bishop D6 coming up next so if you
play a king H1 for example Bishop D6 is
very strong so Knight F D5 the best
option Knight C takes D5 you cannot take
with the Knight because after Knight D5
you're going to be losing the bishop at
the end only two so you have to you have
to take or actually you have another
option here the move F4
so let's take a look after F4 what's
gonna happen here so black can continue
with the move Bishop C5 check right King
H1
and now you can play uh Queen E6
and here's white is forced to capture
now
Knight takes D5
and if you take Knight takes D5 you are
just gonna be much worse in this
position after move Queen into in fact
close to be losing wow and if you take
Rook takes E2 now Bishop F5 is coming up
with the bishop E4 idea
so Knight C7 and here it's amazing
position you don't even need to move the
Rook here you can actually play the move
Bishop D7 sacrifice The Rook because
the attack is very strong Bishop C6
attacking on G2 and if you play Rook G1
there is a very nice Checkmate
and again we see once again why you need
to develop your pieces because otherwise
you could be in a receiving end of this
kind of mate
so wow yeah so it's very very uh
dangerous to play like this of course I
don't expect dink to do this but here
it's already much worse here you have to
you don't have to take on D5 you can
play let's say Bishop F3 and hope to
equalize maybe in this position ic3
Queen C3 but black is already very
slightly better here because there are
some weaknesses in this position
and ding definitely needs a win as he
and nepo are tied for seventh through
Ninth Place you know both on minus one
uh running out of track as they say I
mean not too many games to go right
exactly uh the other Marquee matchup we
haven't seen it in some time let's jump
to Fabi versus alireza when we left it
we left it in a position we just thought
that white had a more harmonious
development he's already connected his
Rooks it has Fabi and he's ready to
bring his Rooks into the center of the
board continue to grab more Central
files Rook ac1 Knight H5 an indication
that not everything's uh copacetic with
uh his position Bishop takes G7 1967
Rook C8 and white is the first to grab
the OPEC file how can you leverage that
into some material advantage well a
trade of Bishops 95. again blacks piece
is a little bit
not so harmonious I'm ready to play
Knight F3 it's almost kind of like a
Catalan position at a group felt
position now I see them of Queen D5 and
I think that a lot of players would be
attracted to that move but then moved to
my eyes has a negative uh that
um
it's funny that sorry it looks like the
most centralized and move exactly why is
it not so good exactly so I'm sitting
there saying
um the knights on E5 and F3 make a good
impression but in some ways they step on
each other's Hooves they're in the way
of one another the Knight on E5 looks
good but really it's searching for
something more concrete when you see the
move Queen D5 at first you say oh that's
great you centralize everything but in
my way of thinking
you're inviting Knight E3 right
E3 okay what do I mean by 93 it's not
even 93 on the board okay first of all
give me mate and one right I mean like
that's a varossing right a surprise I'm
threatening check mate in one move so
you block okay either way it doesn't
matter H5 or F6 you block the threat now
Knight E3 so your queen which is lording
over the position on D5 suddenly gets
the boot okay where do you go
the other night will come to E5 the
other night will come because if you go
to D6 now this guy's a little bit
offsides so you start to I start to ask
more more probing Salient questions now
and I see uh more Harmony in the white
side again my Rook is already in the
game if your Rook was on d8 I would kind
of think that the advantage is a little
bit less but I do feel like the momentum
the trend is with for uh pardon me with
Fabi and that farugia has got to make
some exacting moves now am I right or am
I wrong in the sense that Queen D5
I think was the wrong move for
I think that that's helpful to White is
that fair or unfair
uh Queen D5 it's it's not that bad
Yasser but there were other moves in
particular the move Queen D6 perhaps
would have been a little bit better here
because in that line as you mentioned
Knight G4 at some point Knight Will land
on E3 with the extra tempo right uh
Block's position is not that bad here in
fact you could even get away with
playing the move F6 in this position it
kick the Knight away kick the Knight
away and then you don't you never have
to worry about that Knight G4 and Knight
H6 Checkmate idea so that way you don't
have to waste another Tempo there but
let's take a look what is the best way
Fabi can continue here to apply some
pressure I feel like this is very
important moment here to drive Rook C3
while you were talking Rook C3 okay
let's see
um that was a move I didn't really
consider myself yeah it's a good move
it's definitely a good move the idea he
wants to also play the move Rook D3 here
um as as I was mentioning it's very
important to try to play concrete here
while this Rook is not in the game the
Knight is misplaced because if you give
block few moves to consolidate the
position then I think you're probably
not going to have Advantage here so I
like this move Rook C3 and it's it's
putting some questions certainly that
black needs to solve here so let's see
what are the options here Rook A8 is one
option to try to bring the Rook into the
game again not a very natural move
because you know there's not much going
to be happening here and you still have
a knight on F5 so but that's one of the
best moves white is still better here
because he's trying to play the move
Rook D3 attack the queen and then get
the Rook
Rook D7 and it's hard to play like this
and now you have to go back to E8 so I
don't think alireza will be very
comfortable to play like this that feels
very unnatural yes yes and now the other
option here guys is to play the move
Knight C5 this I think makes more sense
because you want to at least prevent the
move Rook D3 Rook D3 in this position
okay of course but the problem with this
move is you're allowing a move Queen B5
and now your Knights are hanging and it
looks very very awkward here but you you
do have this move B6
wow and again thanks to the tactics this
somehow works because you cannot take on
B6 because of the clever move Knight A4
forking the queen and Rook again not an
easy move to find you just don't look
this kind of mousse because it looks
kind of the pieces are very loose here
but if Knight C5 is probably his best
option here and
you can play for example this now Knight
A4 is a threat actually so so perhaps
you can play this one because it's very
direct now this move so Rook C2 you can
play now you're threatening to play Rook
D2
and you have to find a move now Queen D6
only move here otherwise pieces are
hanging here Queen D6 now Rook D2
attacking the queen queen E6
but even here now Knight G5 is coming I
think it's a very difficult position to
play for black here and he has to play
very accurately to
try to equalize here but I think it's uh
very difficult I like what's what Fabi
is doing and I like his chances in this
position thank you for as we are about
to take some tweets I just have to
mention that a long thing by dingler in
provoked a move that
feels like a bitter lemonade uh swallow
uh Queen E5 we liked Wesley's position
we were thinking castles whether you
like it or not more or less obligatory
you know you gotta get your king out of
the center this e-file is menacing
Knight H3 after a long think
whoa my Canada move sorry to say that
looks terrible that's not a move that a
world champion really wants to play
because the most compelling obvious move
you can imagine
d65 by Wesley trying to blast open the
e-file as well as Play Bishop takes H3
and I think dingler in is in trouble and
in fact we do have G5 Bishop F4 right
I'm trying to guess his idea please when
he was looking at Castle he probably
didn't like how his Queen side would
stay and developed for so long right so
he came up with this interesting idea
which might not work but Knight H3 right
Bishop F4 and long Castle
Bishop F4 which is a Tempo okay that's a
good that's a good thing and by the way
we are tickling the Knight on C7 so more
or less I feel unless I'm playing D
takes DTX C4 is a good possibility as
well yeah unless I can get get into
swishin Zug with d takes because your
attack my queen I attack your queen you
take my knight I take your Bishop can I
take Knight if four here well that I in
in the immortal words of uh Nikolai
manev gift me your Pawn uh green takes
B2 right this happens
yes yes yes
and things are getting uh Wild and
Woolly uh the the king is still stuck in
the center
F6 is hanging I'm gonna sacrifice at
peace I'm gonna hang around
gonna hang around I will be greedy and
take the night good for you that's what
I wanted to see uh be greedy take the
night
uh let's uh well you got married F2 yeah
yeah Knight F2 is not uh what I maybe
this was too big of a sacrifice well
wait wait wait wait wait my Spidey Sense
is still like
well hmm How can I
this guy I I want to make an overworked
I want to make a tactic where you have
an overworked Queen uh don't think if
your Bishop was developed it would have
worked but okay I think here why it's
why it's doing okay so Queen takes B2
Rook B1 is it is there a follow-up here
of our
I don't think we can get away with
giving up the piece here but but we
don't even need to yeah so Queen E7 is
just played by Wesley immediately I also
like this movie just keeping the tension
on the board right and Viking is still
stuck in the center Bishop H3 move is a
possible and to now ding has to play uh
some accurate moves but he still works
here much worse here in fact the best
continuation here is CTX D5 clear and
then can White Castle long uh without or
without taking no with with to take this
okay she takes D5 she takes D5 yeah cast
along it's it's it's probably the best
option okay but now
block can play Bishop takes
H3 developing and immediately taking the
Knight and now we take back
and now we have also this move for
Knight E6 attacking the bishop that's it
yeah I see some problems coming up with
the move roxier the king is not going to
be very safe here
so Bishop E3
right
Rook ac8
now you probably want to put the King on
B1 here immediately attack the king as
well takes only four right and there are
some problems on the e-file here as well
so 94 is the best option if you take
with the pawn after Knight C5 you're
gonna have to take on C5 and this is a
move that you don't really want to play
because this position just is really bad
here you don't have any control play
here and that was your only good piece
the bishop that yeah I'm not happy so
and if you take with the Knight try to
at least preserve pair of the Bishops
you can play Knight takes E4
and again after F takes C4 Knight C5
you're gonna have to give up the bishop
and uh this looks too simple for uh
Wesley this is a dream position for
Wesley and this is the best way white
can play White doesn't play like this he
could actually just lose the game
immediately because the way he played it
looks very suspicious yeah so the king
is still in the middle a lot of
weaknesses the Knight on H3 is misplaced
yeah it just uh doesn't feel right what
ding is doing in this game uh truly uh
we only have 15 moves on the board and
to be this worse with white after 15.
not a not a good outing at all before
the games get too interesting though let
me let's just pause the show for a
second and invite the uh
um viewers to come and join the
conversation we have some tweets now see
this one is from Tapas Zapata who would
be the eight candidates for a 60 years
old plus Championship
no idea
definitely yes sir I'm still celebrating
my 40th and if you believe that I've got
a bridge I'd like to saw you know um no
I don't know I have no idea well I mean
in my generation you had Nigel short and
you know uh Dr John Nunn and Robert it's
Gary up there Gary's getting up there he
just turned 60 Gary yeah okay he's just
yeah so yeah they're that well look it
up they've got to be there's got to be
some 60 plus uh senior list senior list
yeah senior list yes more tweets thank
you for the question by the way Queen
Revival asks from twitch
why do you think emotions and shares are
so hard to control and what can be done
to better manage them coach you got to
jump in you you probably get that all
the time
stay calm stay calm yeah it's safe
definitely very emotional sometimes if
you're so close to win a big tournament
and then you fail it then all of us had
those moments it's it's very hard it's a
very emotional game you put a lot of
efforts sometimes you play five six
hours and then at the end of the game
you make one silly mistake and you lose
the game I think it's just the nature of
the game and uh you know it's uh there's
not much you can do about it but if you
can control and just be more calm that
will really help and I think that's what
ding Loren does it's very hard to tell
sometimes if you won the game or he drew
the game his emotions are pretty much
the same and that's that's that's a
strength if you can have that experience
is the best fact I was going to say that
yeah it takes a lot of experience and uh
just practice that sometimes you're
going to lose and it's you have to get
used to it yeah it takes time playing
through the pain I mean in the barbaric
Northwest we talk about the howler so
the idea is you're at the club you're
playing your your toughest rival you
know you really really want to beat your
opponent who always seems to somehow get
the better of you you have a winning
position finally it's like yes I've got
this I've got this you make a move
that's so bad that not only does it ruin
the position but it almost guarantees
you your loss being the kind gentle
person you are you politely resign you
sign the score sheets you walk out the
club and then you scream to high heaven
why am I such an idiot and yeah chess
brings out the emotion because in sport
and chess is Sport you are going to
experience highs and lows in the world
of Chess like none other sport can
possibly do because
everything you're responsible for
everything you you didn't make a good
pass you didn't your teammate didn't
drop the ball you're the one who you
know experiences the highs and lows
because it's all about you and your
ideas so it's tough
it's tough and all I can say is keep
playing keep playing keep playing you'll
you you'll get better you'll get you'll
learn how to deal with it best I mean
it's a mentally very tough game so
that's expected
one last tweet as we get back uh into
the game so thank you very uh tough
question this one is from
toy voches
what was your most difficult loss and
how did you read
to my mind I know what my most difficult
loss was what did you what was your most
difficult loss how did you rebound right
I was uh 16 years old uh that was when
you immediately no too right yeah it
still hurts it still hurts me too I was
in the Russian Super Final uh playing
against the Olympic Champions costing
you can all the strong players I'm in
the first place and the last round with
white pieces I need a draw to win the
championship first place
all you need is a draw and I'm playing
the last set of the tournament who was
not having a great tournament
fantastic a dream come true with a
script writers I got checkmated in 25
moves
checkmated it's generated in 25 most yes
and all you needed was a draw to win the
Russian Championship that would have
been a huge success to finish the
question how I rebounded
oh
pieces at all anymore how distraught you
must have been yeah it still hurts like
I said sometimes I in my nightmares it
still comes up exactly I know mine what
about you VAR uh mine is also very clear
and in fact Yasser you were there in
that same tournament 2003 U.S
Championship yes last round to where
there was an eight-way tie for the first
place and uh three pairs made quick
draws and I was playing Alex shabalov
for all the marbles all the marbles and
this was my first U.S championship
appearance and I actually got a wild
card in that tournament right and we get
into this French defense Advanced
vibration I'm doing I think really well
with two extra pawns but it was very
complicated I think I was much better at
some point but I misplayed it and end up
losing that game so which could have
been my first U.S Championship win if I
had win that game clear first and uh in
the first appearance winning the
championship I think I would qualify to
the World Cup get my second Grand Master
drone so it was really tough right but
the way I bounce back actually just few
months later I played in a open
tournament in Vermont and I actually
played against Alex ravalov we played a
lot those years and I won with the black
pieces against in a French defense
amazing wow but in terms of overcoming
the loss I mean did how did you
internalize it and say okay
uh I remember you actually told me that
we didn't know each other that well but
you told me VAR what doesn't kill you
make you stronger right so and that's
what I did it was very tough because
it's such a big loss it could have
really changed my whole life if I had to
win the U.S championship at that point
but I just continued train continue work
hard I had the Samford fellowship at
that point so I had some support and I
just continued training and I became a
grand master later that year right
exactly for me I had a situation where
in those days they had what were these
very tough grueling events called the
interzonals and they were qualifiers for
the candidates
so with two games to go I was in a great
position to become a candidate wow you
know like we we saw that earlier
graphic that VAR had showed and I think
for a lot of grand Masters that's very
important for them to become a candidate
and a world champion right so this was
my chance to become a candidate with two
games to go all I needed to do was make
a draw Victor korchnoy draw my last game
I'm in but I've got this test with
Victor
so I played my normal routine everything
was fine and in those days you could
offer a draw and then again all I needed
was a draw and I was in the candidate so
in a more or less equal position I offer
Victor or Draw and immediately came this
no
you bet me so I I can't even imitate
it's like no you know so I don't know
what happened to us but at that moment I
said right well now I'm gonna
really punish you right so victor goes
all out trying to beat me
so I'm in a situation where I can force
a draw like just force a draw which is
what I wanted become a candidate life is
good right no
I find a variation where I think I'm
winning by force so of course I'm going
to win by force I play the variation as
a refutation he finds it he destroys me
from a force position Robert Byrne goes
in the New York Times calls the
brilliancy of the year you know like
when I blundered the game away and there
I am in a situation where the candidates
is going away now I have a forced win in
the last round if I can win I can make
it to the candidates and I do
because in that moment I stopped myself
and said look I just blew it great but I
didn't blow it completely I still have
that window of becoming a candidate and
I did rebound by what's the next day
next day right like so it was really you
know the roller coaster ride the
emotional roller coaster ride of like
well what an idiot I am and hey I still
can win so being a champion yeah you're
gonna fall a lot and often getting up a
lot of questions to immediately bounce
back precisely that's what I think is
all about when you compare every one of
these world champions trust me when I
say they've been tested they've been
tested severely and they kept bouncing
back talking about the world champion
for just a moment dingler in versus
Wesley so Jump Right In uh VAR and tell
me what has happened since we left it
so since we left a few moves has been
played here and let's take a look in
this position now
um Knight F21 he did not he did not play
long Castle which we analyzed so he
played Knight F2
uh again very very risky position for
white here and Wesley played 96
immediately putting pressure on the
bishop and Bishop E3 move is played Just
white is just trying to hang on hoping
that you know he can castle and somehow
not to lose immediately and here is a
critical moment here Wesley needs to
find the best move here to have a big
Advantage he can perhaps have a small
Advantage if he takes only four Knight F
E4 Knight takes E4 and if you play uh
Queen E4 there is a bishop D7 with idea
Bishop C6 black is slightly better Dash
so but the the strongest move in this
position is this move d4
and I think racy is going to find this
move because it's a it's a natural move
you want to really win this D4 uh win
the dark Square Bishop here so Bishop D4
is forced
then now you play this move Rook d8
peeling the bishop and the only way to
get out of this is to play Bishop takes
F6 now Queen takes F6 again Queen is
still under attack and a lot of dark
Square weaknesses Bishop C5 is going to
be played at some point and once again
the queen is still hanging
so
you have to play either Knight D5 but
Knight D5 Queen B2 that looks really
good for black the other option is to
play Knight G4 try to attack the queen
but now Queen G5 comes in
the dark squares are really terribly
weak in this position here so Queen E3
and now Knight F4 threatening Knight
takes
G2 and now you have to find the oh this
is this is amazing you have to find the
only move here guys H4 allowing Knight
takes G2 alien chess yeah I don't think
this is really gonna happen but we can
just look at the line just in case
Knight G2 King to F2 Knight E3
takes on G5 Knight G4 check and now but
this is this is just extremely extremely
set position here for white and this is
the best way white can play Imagine
that's amazing variation you just showed
because the moment you gave me the
position on the board I saw the move d4
and I said I like it but I liked it for
a completely different reason was after
Bishop takes D4 you showed a line that
went Rook d8 I thought the Knight was
going to jump to F4 because I saw a fork
and taking on G2
compromising White's King and and I
thought okay blacks clearly better why
didn't you play Knight F4 Knight F4
actually loses the advantage completely
because it takes a lot of moves to win
the pawn back and white has this strong
center with E4 and F3 so I will show you
why uh so Queen D2 is the only move we
can play Queen E3 obviously because of
Knight G2 so you take on G2 and now King
goes to F1 okay and you have to play the
move Knight Alpha and the Knight is
doing a very good job here because if
Bishop H3 comes in it's just going to be
game over right so in this position
actually white has a pretty you know
good decent development here black still
has a bishop Rook on it and you can
actually even play the move Queen G5
here
it's a little bit safe here you go back
Knight to G6 right and here white can't
even try to get aggressive now with F4
okay getting aggressive while you're
while you're King is on F1 and you weak
and E4 okay yeah because you know my
once again this Knight on F2 guys is
doing a fantastic job protecting E4 and
it's amazing and somehow this works this
white is actually fine here wow because
I I yeah me too I was sitting there
going oh D4 Knight F4 take the pawn on
G2 but it's Rook d8
and a key move yeah and then finally
also because I know what a very
practical player uh Wesley so as taking
on e4 you were saying black is for
choice because the king is still in the
center Knight takes E4 Knight takes E4
again it looks like there's going to be
an accident down the e-file
yeah he actually played Yasser D4 and
Rook d8 yeah and he forced the win of
the dark Square Bishop as you prescribed
and again uh
remarkable Insight thereby Wesley not to
play Knight F4 which is a dead end it
turns out he evaluates just like the
entrance
fantastic Rook d8 Bishop F6 Queen takes
F6 and it's all about the dark squares a
D4 F4 Bishop is coming to C5 as VAR
mentioned G55 is going to be met by
Queen B2 and I'm not Material down I've
got the two Bishops and I've got dark
Square control Queen E3 and that was a
no it was Knight G4 you said Knight G4
is the best move Nike for Queen G5
and the Knight is coming to F4 dark
squares dark squares and wow great stuff
really good for black it really does
look good for everybody
uh let's just as we prepare for a
commercial break one quick look at the
standings once more we're coming into
round five this is the standings Nasi we
have Fabiano caruana lead in the
tournament with three and a half points
and quickly following firusha so and
Robert the chasing pack indeed and again
Bobby versus farugia is a key Marquee
matchup Rook C3 Fabian played that some
time ago the Rouge has been in a think
tank we're gonna take a break and we'll
see you on the other side
foreign
[Music]
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
over the roughly one and a half
Millennium of its existence chess has
been known as a tool of military
strategy a metaphor for human affairs
[Music]
thank you
meet me at the beauty the beauty in
Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedy's romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
in Forest Park
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the superbet chess
classic in beautiful Bucharest Romania
here are our standings after round five
Nasi to be honors right we have a little
Fabiano Carolina with three and a half
points and close the following Fairuza
so and rapper with three points
absolutely and let's just jump into the
games between Bobby and Ali Reza for a
moment when we have left it we had seen
this move Rook C3
that's a kind of interesting
Queen D5 I liked Knight G4 Knight E3 as
my choice but Rook C3
caused a long think and eventually I
think alireza found one of the best
moves in the position the engine
approved Rook A8 Rook D3 Queen C5 so
both players can you really slowed down
a great deal on these last few moves as
you know white needs in the next move or
two to prove his advantage or whether he
has an advantage please both sides need
to make such precise moves five minutes
precise moves to get an advantage and
feroza has to be very careful to not end
up in a much worse position that's why
they're both thinking so much right in
this position you know white is
essentially if you will is teleported
his Rook to uh the open D file and in
this case you got to ask the question oh
I'm on the open D file I want to go to
the seventh rank on a good day I want to
boot that Queen take a pawn and will the
move Rook D7 bring any tangible results
for what say ye
Rook D7 is one of the best moves in this
position and again black needs to play
some very accurate moves here let's take
a look what he should do here so Rook D7
um rookie 8 is the move I think we might
have mentioned this earlier another
option is actually just to play Rook C8
what really yeah it's a very calm move
and just just trying to control the C
file for a moment of course the line
that is critical is the move Knight D3
trying to deflect the queen from C5 and
try to pick up the pawn only seven in
this case black sacrifices the pawn
with Queen C3 okay Queen takes C3 Rook
takes C3 give me the block E7
Rook C2
trying to put pressure on it too but
white is actually better here after the
move King F1 so I think this line is uh
uh King F1 Knight C6 I mean there are
some chances but we're gonna enter into
this this type of endgame Yasser where
you have four on three and uh but if you
gave me this position and I didn't have
a chess engine in front of me I would
say I'm winning I mean I'm a pawn up and
I have after 95 obvious uh I mean I know
what I'm doing I'm targeting F7 so I
would be shocked that this is something
that farugia would willingly play even
if the engine says the key about this
position is actually very important not
to trade the knights try to achieve a
position like this where you can trade
The Rook once you trade the Rooks there
are a lot of positions where we cannot
win with two knights so at the moment
basically what black needs to do it like
if you get into this end game you need
to trade this pawns and you can lose
both of your Knights so I think that's
the reason why there are decent drawing
chances in this particular end game for
blackish but of course you don't have to
trade the Rooks here I think if I was
playing I would try to somehow keep the
Rook on the board maybe play this
position Rook B2 and but now it's no
longer there is a danger on the seventh
Rank and again uh the problem here is if
we trade Rooks I have all this this
chances that you cannot just win with
the Knight so um difficult defense ahead
here but black has some chances in this
in this end game definitely so let's
take a look at some other Alternatives
here after Rook D7 here what about
Knight f8 Knight f8 right here yes
Knight f8 right here actually again same
problem so looks like after Rook D7 we
always have to watch out for this move
Knight D3 that's the main threat in the
position right the pawn only seven
in all the cases I'm grabbing that pawn
on these yeah so for that reason Rook E8
let's take a look at Rook 8 I think it's
a very logical move just now we're not
um we're not that afraid of this move
Knight D3 anymore but here white can
still play Knight D3 or you also have
the option just to play A4
I like this move controlling to the the
B5 square and just asking black what is
your next move
and it's not easy to to answer that
because you can really move your pieces
there are really no Targets in this
position yes you can try to play this
move Knight C4 try to liquidate one pair
of the knights but still now I don't
want to lose my a pawn so I will push A5
and we're gonna get to one of these end
games eventually here take zombie seven
rookie seven so something like this is
expected four on three big Advantage for
white but not easy to convert wow okay
but uh still big Advantage probably on a
lifetime results Head to Head yeah has
three wins and only one loss right and
Vara mentioned the fide
uh
[Music]
Swiss Grand Swiss that they they
competed uh against one another Fabi
winning that game now he he hasn't
played Rook D7 yet uh we'll keep an eye
again
waiting for it but okay it was worth the
wait uh nice uh this is a huge game for
our current standings but a huge game
for Wesley so
and World Champion Dean Lauren is
suffering he's suffering
I just want to address one move that was
played by Duda oh wonderful let's do it
that was this very very visual move we
get to this position you know we we were
just coming in and broadcast right now
see and queen D5 like in your face you
want to move uh you're welcome to take
my queen but at the result is that uh I
get two Rooks uh for the queen and I'm
doing great as a result of the move
Queen D5 dude has moved Queen D5 nepo
had to back up and they said okay okay I
kicked you back I'll I'll step back as
well I would just be happy that I
yeah I moved like yeah it is a very very
attractive move no question about it uh
Richie how is MBL and Richie report
because uh this was the French defense
game and I really found myself drawn to
uh what I think is a great strategic
fight the position has has become very
very closed after somehow we left it
here takes takes and since this bishop
isn't on F6
black said you know what this is really
nice now I'm ready to play Bishop to E8
and uh you put a little pressure on the
H5 Pawn
and well this bishop is not that great
on E2 either it's playing more or less a
pretty passive as he explained earlier
in this type of uh opening black has the
advantage on the queen side yes why it
has advantage in the center and King
side sure but I I hear it looks like
Richard has equalized on the king side
as well well one of the things that
French defense players will tell you is
when they've equalized they feel they've
got the advantage because it's sort of
like the trend from the start has been
in White's favor white has the space and
he's got the two Bishops and then
suddenly when black equalizes it's
almost like it's a continuation of the
equalization and uh I got a feeling that
after Richie just played the move Knight
C8 you know you see a move like Queen A1
I look across the board and I say thank
you Queen A1 like you know like boy
that's an that's what I call an
intimidating move I don't know about you
VAR but when my opponents play Queen A1
in such positions uh I stopped smirking
and laughing and I tip my hat say Well
done what about you yeah absolutely I
think black is uh quite happy here uh he
achieved the most he could achieve I
think in the French defense uh but I
think in this position we might just see
um sort of a steel mate in repetition
where neither side can really make much
progress here because I think the plan
for Richie is to try to bring let's say
Knight C6 to A7 to B5 but then NVA will
play uh even move the king to D1 and
Bishop C1 he needs to defend this A3
pawn and then it will be one of those
positions where neither side can do much
there is no entry on a g file even
though it looks nice but you can't
really enter so but we can take a look
but right now the engines are showing
just zero zero zero
right but it does look okay maybe the
Queen's a little awkward on A4 but boy
the queen looks really strange on A1
Richie by the way did play the move
Bishop D7 more or less intimating
something you've just suggested that
neither side can really Force matters
actually he can uh White can play Queen
B2 back here for example oh okay not
putting pressure on B6 so you can't
really move anything you have to try to
improve this c69 and the idea is let's
say you played Knight two uh uh A7 yes
Knight six to A7 he plays Bishop F2 okay
and when you bring the Knight to B5 yes
it looks great but I can simply defend
the A3 pawn and now you have your knight
is stuck and your queen cannot move in
this position and uh yes you can maybe
try to bring this bishop on F6 but
you're not really gonna accomplish much
by doing that I think it's very
important to keep the Knight on C8 to
prevent the Bishop from coming to E7 and
Knight on C8 is also doing a good job
protecting the pan on B6 so let's say
right place
if King B7 Bishop H4
again you can just
sit here and yes Bishop gets to the F6
it looks great but you really don't have
a plan in this position so I think we
gonna see a position like this where
neither side can do much and they will
probably repeat the position
suggesting that mvl might have said a
little bit of a trap with his last move
Queen A1 the idea is that if you do play
the move Knight A7 and Knight B5 and you
you know you think it's it's all about
me it's all about my great ideas the
move Rook G1
might prove you wrong it's just it's the
sentence which where go ahead uh we're
taken with the questions yeah do me a
favor take my A3 Pawn I will take the H6
pawn and then it might be a race yeah
is it the H Pawn or is it the a pawn and
maybe the move Queen A1 is intimating
hey I'm I'm looking to play Rook uh to
G1 and that may explain better why
Richard just said okay Bishop D7 you
want to go Rook G1 I'll take it and in
that case I'll take it and you're not
playing Queen G7 shag and doing
everything with the tempo King
D1 suggesting once again that
white has more or less reached his
Zenith he's got the best setup he can
and well very very hard to for either
player to do much okay if they're stuck
what's going on in the game between dioc
and Anish Yuri when we left we really
thought that finally uh Daniel was
playing one of his very very best games
uh he just played the move Knight A4
looking at the B6 Square you were saying
Nasi if we can play B3 and C4 uh we've
got a a real nice rip on the position
okay Anish understands his baking is
being cooked you better do something he
played Knight G4 takes takes Bishop drop
back C4 and I quickly catch up with the
players
um G4 Queen E4 last moving the G4 are
you like yeah the desirable white plate
already G4 yeah the desirable Queen G4
has a hiccup G4 Queen C6 uh provokes G4
right
he did it might be a disadvantage on the
king side right but at the moment since
block doesn't have a wide squared Bishop
right it looks like White's King is safe
indeed it does maybe we just need to
transfer our pieces a little bit maybe
Knight C3 should we go back to D5 it's
the original exactly exactly it just
feels like this Knight on C7
is more or less stuck you never really
ever want to see this Knight just land
on D5 in the meantime you have provoked
G4 but you know you start thinking about
it a little bit more you go well wait a
minute if I could play and I mean it
looks a little bit okay devilish to go
but why to you want to put King on G3 so
that I can play H4 G4 in the meantime
the stock the apartment Black's pieces
feel a little bit stuck you're you're
ready to meet white whatever white does
right but yeah that's sit on weight yeah
you're waiting and maybe King G3
H4 could be the camel that breaks the
back Bishop G5
Daniel as we know has been in time
trouble virtually this whole tournament
how is he doing today at least on the
clock doing quite well he has 28 minutes
that's a huge Improvement has 22.
you must be upset
it's like who am I playing today the guy
who's been playing in the tournament has
two minutes for his last 20 moves
the guy I'm playing
is ahead on the clock yeah and he's got
the better position Anish must be
feeling very frustrated at the moment
bar
absolutely and he just played the move
Bishop G5 which looks looks good but I
think there are going to be some
problems for him on the D6 Pawn he's
trying to exchange the bishop because
clearly the bishop only three is uh more
active than the bishop only seven but
one thing the bishop only seven was
doing is actually defending this weak
Pawn on D6 here let's take a look at the
current position right now the
evaluation is actually much better for
white it's like plus one here but let's
see how the ACT can try to continue here
to increase his the pressure on anisha's
position so let's see Bishop G5 now
he should take first Now Pawn takes
and here's a
um there there are a few different ways
he can play in this position but he can
even play this move King H2 that you
pointed out earlier this is actually a
good place to put the king and uh so
it's not going to be any checks on the
back Rank and at some point if it's an
A-game King will be a little bit closer
uh to go to G3 perhaps so black doesn't
have anything can really do here has to
stay here and just try to defend this D6
Pawn here one one alternative is try to
get maybe some activity with a move D5
wow because you can't take with a pawn
the C3 is hanging but here we have
Knight takes D5
Rook takes D5
and now play the move e-force
hmm
and maybe try to play Queen C7 check
there is a little bit of a pressure here
on B3 as well just to sacrifice the pawn
try to play more actively here but white
is better after uh a few options here
Rook d8 is one option just try to trade
another option is to play Queen D2
and now put pressure on G5
if let's say F6 trying to protect and
then you can play Queen D Force actually
centralize the queen and put pressure
again this line is not really four so
it's possible that Anish would not play
the move D5 here and if he just tries to
uh if you don't do anything you just
wait here let's say King f8
then white can improve the position with
Rook D3
now King GA let's say you're just
waiting here and now
even the move like H4 might be
interesting because if you capture
G5 and then suddenly the queen is going
to come to H5 Rook H3 Rook H4 so there
are some attacking chances here for deck
as well in this position so black needs
to do something after exchanging the
Bishops here and uh because there could
be some uh attacking options with this
Rook D3 H4 as well here white is clearly
better here sure feels like it to me too
I want to turn our attention to the game
between nepo and Duda for just a moment
because we saw that visual move Queen uh
D5 uh Nasi and since that move has been
played there's been a couple of
repetitions and we may be looking at our
first result in this the sixth round
game as uh the players have been
repeating nepo uh is not at the board
yeah exactly uh and then nepo is not at
the board but it is move and because
this queen you know you'd kind of think
okay well let me play Queen A6 or
something like this but the whole idea
behind Queen D5 is I've got my uh play
as well don't forget this isn't the most
beautiful uh King you've ever seen
before and maybe even Queen then maybe
there's something even to be said for
Queen here so that I can play Knight
takes D4 on a good day and I've got
Queen check or even simply Queen D6 back
I still don't see how white is going to
improve this position well true that but
I was thinking well wait a minute I mean
move Queen D5 I'd really love to
teleport my queen to A1 check right and
kind of disturb a little uh bit from
from uh behind uh again because it's
such an important game uh dingler in
versus uh Wesley so
by the way Wesley played we looked at
the these variations of VAR did some
time ago and Wesley has played each time
the engines most accurate first move but
I had a question for you uh Nasi when I
show you the move Queen H4 check
and you say well I gotta play G3 because
my queen is hanging I've got no choice
and I I asked you what do you think
about this ending is black I mean
you you you're pawned down but in a fact
in effect the the extra Pawn that you
have on your pocket is the Pawn on H2
not exactly your pride and joy you know
no go going around telling the world you
know like how brilliant you are you've
got an extra Pawn but those dark squares
it looks
absolutely preferable for black exactly
but I think
black had so many good options in their
position exactly that he's chosen even
more aggressive right continuation with
keeping the Queens on the board because
as we already know white king is still
in the center and doesn't have any
either Castle looks bad yes so I think
uh Wesley already played Queen A5 Queen
A5 I was about to say yes black is
completely dominated on the black
squares it certainly is that there's no
question about that Queen A5
okay again
this and and you don't you know the
desirable castles uh is always running
in the bishop C5 so there's no chance
that white will ever be able to to to to
put his Queen on this diagonal Queen A5
again the queen Senator attack so this
move this one I mentioned the way Wesley
is looking at the position it's just
like sitting and enjoying his position
exactly look at my beautiful black
squares truly that uh Queen comes back
to C7
um
oftentimes amateur players ask me the
question when should I be trading queens
and when shouldn't I and I say so many
times the answer to the question is King
safety right King safety look across the
board Black's King is perfectly safe
whites Queen has no chance of attacking
the black
King so black is not interested in
changing in Queens white King on the
other hand has a vulnerability sitting
on E1 it would be egregiously
wrong of black to agree to trade Queens
under these circumstances once you see
Queen C7 you go oh
your heart skips the beat I think if
Wesley were to take on B5 he would get a
kiss like you were playing yeah yes
exactly yeah there you go thank you for
that Wesley you you've made my day but
now the move Quincy said I don't know
VAR I'm looking at this position and I
have nothing good to say about ding's
play thus far he's got a pawn in the
pocket but that's about it absolutely
he's he's in big big trouble here Wesley
played all the precise moves with Queen
A5 uh and now Queen C7 The Queen Is
Gonna land on G3 momentarily Knight F4
is coming up as well it's it's a winning
Advantage for Block winning winning
Advantage it's possible plus three
pretty much here and uh by just looking
at the position we can tell also the
dark squares are so weak and things went
really really bad for dingler and in
this game here and uh I expect Wesley to
to win this one what is going on with
doing again uh he got the number one
seed in the drawing of lots which means
he started with two whites which is
always a very very nice feeling uh in
this uh type of a round robin of such
great caliber this is his fourth game
with the white pieces out of six
not only he's not one a game but his
white games have been just nothing
impressive about them he's he's just
he's not in his Zone
he must be absolutely exhausted and I
think we saw him in the interviews too
yesterday and the days before where he
just he needs to rest yeah well he just
had the rest day that was what we were
all thinking he didn't really have a
rest day unlike other players him and
rapper had to do press conferences did
he yes okay so that could be affecting
him too exactly but he's looking at this
position VAR you didn't tell us how you
know
with engine Precision play What on earth
is ding supposed to do because I mean
I'm just have I'm struggling coming up
with a a plan 95 is the best move in
this position
blockade the D file here okay and put
pressure on the queen so Queen G3 will
be played yep very natural move now
check and also the G2 Pawn is hanging I
you can't really put the King on the D5
that will be really bad you cannot also
play Knight F2 because of Bishop C5
putting pressure on the pin piece so you
have to play the smooth King F1
and here actually Wesley needs to find
the best move here which I think he will
find here is this move Rook takes D5
eliminating this Knight but the ID is
you want to put this Knight on F4 if you
play it immediately then white can
exchange and try to hang on so this is
very important to move Rook takes D5
Queen takes D5 simply loses to the move
Knight F4 and then you have to move the
queen and queen G2 wins the game so you
have to play e takes D5 Knight F4 still
activating the Knight and now
threatening Queen takes G2 right only
move here not for to not to lose
immediately is is 93 here because black
also threatening to capture on G4 and
bring the Rook into the game so 93 only
move just trying to defend here and
here's not an easy move to find but you
need this move A6
to remove the queen from there and to
potentially bring the bishop to C5 here
so now Queen has to stay around the C5
Square so let's say queen B6
and now Bishop F5 developing the bishop
and with the idea to play rookie once
The Rook lands only eight it's going to
be very difficult because your knight is
vulnerable and will be many threats here
so this is the absolute best line for
ding D6
Rook E8 now he needs to find a move Rook
G1 only move just to defend on G2 and
here's black can play Bishop D7
and
rookie one just try to bring more
Defenders
and now Knight takes E2
Rook takes E2
and Bishop B5 is strong but also Rook C8
very strong threatening now Rook C1 this
king is really really vulnerable here on
F1 here
so 91 Rook C1 and uh Bishop B5 is coming
as well so it's still around plus and
now it's plus four almost but again not
easy to find all these moves I think for
both players I'm very forcibly reminded
of the Great American writer Reuben Fein
who said about the move Rook takes D5
As Natural as a baby smile Rook takes D5
I love that move that's a great move
what an exchange sci-fi Rook takes D5 e
takes D5 Knight F4 double threat Queen
takes G2 uh Bishop takes G4 Knight has
to drop back uh A6 a nice move uh
prepping Bishop C5 you have to play
Queen here we understand the moment we
play rookie eight it's game over just
like that's it it's Splat Bishop F5 is a
good move I also like some for some
reason Bishop bg7 Bishop F5 rookie eight
natural powerful moves as well uh VAR I
mean this could be
one of those games that goes into the
Wesley sews best game collection I mean
it's just you just you just feel what's
going on Knight D5 by the way on the
board and Wesley is being invited to go
Queen G3 check King F1 Rook takes D5
just I mean it's amazing black
sacrifices in exchange they're also
already down upon as well exactly so
it's a polynomial exchange there's no
immediate Checkmate or getting the
material back you have to make moves
like A6 and Bishop F5 right and yet
engine says it's minus four minus four
yes wow that's incredible that's how bad
wise King is on F1 exactly there was one
here in St Louis with a fantastic uh
Blitz event that featured Gary Kasparov
Wesley so and Wesley in a Blitz game
eviscerated Gary's King's Indian
sacrifice sacrifice boom boom boom boom
Gary can came down into the studio kind
of rocked and he said
today we saw morphe versus amateur I was
the amateur I remember that game very
well that was very impressive this this
feels like Wesley at his most Sublime I
mean he is really playing a beautiful
game and I do expect him to find things
he wins today he joins Fabiano depending
on the Falcon yeah but he will go solid
plus two yeah that would uh but that
move Rook takes D5
personally I don't find that to be a
difficult move because
to my way of thinking the move Knight F4
is huge then presence of the night
hitting the pawn on G2 hitting the
bishop on E2 opening up the diagonal
Rook takes D D5 the the move that I
might find the most difficult right here
is actually the move A6 yes the quiet
the quiet move right because you're
thinking to yourself well do I want to
play like I mean don't I want to play
moves like for argument's sake just
throwing it out there like moves like
Knight H3 and you know am I you know
these type I I find myself drawn to
whereas you know Bishop H3 is another
move I might find myself drawn to and
then I start thinking oh I really do get
it now if I move my Bishop I want to
play rookie ape I really want to play
but I can't but it's just perfect the
place at the moment so because the move
Bishop C5 is so powerful I can start
with A6 yeah and then you know it it
leads me down that whole Primrose path
of A6 Queen B6 Bishop F5 and Rook E8 but
boy I mean we'll keep an eye on this
game talking about first place for a
moment what's happening between Fabi and
Ali Reza have we seen precise play uh by
Ali well look at this they're following
the line that you prescribed uh some
time ago actually uh VAR Knight C4 takes
takes what do we got
yeah I think still an advantage for Fabi
there was a very interesting line I
wanted to show you still a little bit
better for Fabi here but let's take a
look
in this position here uh
let's see Rook to D7 nice Rook E8 I
think there was an idea with Knight G4
here yeah Knight G4
F6 he probably uh didn't play this way
because of the move F6 but there was a
very very interesting and a sharp line
here Rook takes E7
what it doesn't look like this should
work right but it's actually uh very
interesting so if you first let's take a
look at Queen takes C7 sure Knight F6
check right so you can go to G7 or um h8
because of 98 check so King F7 is one
option if you go to 1095 check
okay
and King f8 is the only move now if you
take then it's actually a very nice
Checkmate Knight G4 double check F7
Knight H6 king f8 and queen h8 mate
sweet if you go up
here King F5 then check sacrificing all
your pieces and now you have a choice to
checkmate with which Pawn F or H so you
have this
so this was a very interesting idea uh
to try but of course black doesn't have
to play uh the move King takes F6 you
can go back King f8
and white is a little bit better here
and I think this is the end game that
you can get into here Queen B5 check you
get three pounds you get three pawns and
you still have I think winning chances
here but Advantage is not as much here
here
who would even be playing for a win in
this end game I like white because the a
pawn is this disturbing Pawn for the
night if I if you're stuck playing
Knight C7 and keeping the Knight a
little bit passive then I think whites
for Choice by the way we were on a break
and we were talking about Magnus Carlson
and he's he's always looking for
innovative ideas he's got a new company
chess fantasy and how would that work
but VAR put that position with the King
on G4 for just a moment because it
dovetails nicely so in the fantasy role
let's imagine that you have made uh your
picks and your pick is the H2 Pawn you
know I will win the game because my H2
Bond will win the game and somebody
else's fantasy pick F5 right you know
like a million dollars is on the line
will we play H3 or will he play three
and you can see the crowds building up
you know I think that would be a very
funny uh play the H Pawn
um current position current position
this was something that he actually had
this position in our analysis I think
previously yeah and Fabi now has a
choice to get into this end game after
uh Queen takes B7 four on three right so
Queen takes B7 come on you can do it
Knight C5 there is a queen C6 right so
it's not really you're not losing an
exchange so Queen takes A4 and uh
probably can get into this end game and
I think now you have to put the queen on
this diagonal either Queen 8 or queen C6
and uh
H4 perhaps H5 we will see plus one it's
an advantage but uh yeah not easy to
convert this the Knight only six I like
the Knight only six is well placed
controlling the G5 Square so you can
really go there and uh it's gonna be
hard to play this move 95 because you're
currently under the pin if you go to the
background there is a queen C1 check so
white can play this for a long time try
to improve the position but it's not
easy to convert this I think okay uh
let's get in a couple of tweets before
time travel rears its ugly head and here
we go uh where this one is from
Iko kurai from YouTube who asks oh yeah
asterisk books have helped many players
improve their chess but whose books did
Yasin rate himself to learn the game
wonderful question and I want to answer
that question as follows as I evolved as
a chess player certain books that are
played outsized roles in um my career
one book however remained a Perpetual
favorite and that was Michael tall's
book on his 1960 World Championship
Match I read that book as a b player
learned a lot read it as a chess master
thought I was reading it for the first
time read it as an international
Grandmaster I said my God
Misha had great insights you know so
that was a book for the ages it was like
a a a a a a a
Forever Green Book if you will today I
think in terms of authors I just love
Larry Christensen bent Larson David
bronstein Dr John Nunn
as authors and Michael Tall Paul cares
they played such Jeremy Silman Jeremy
wrote some marvelous books really played
outside his roles and it's sort of like
somehow I don't even quite understand it
the right books fell into my hands at
the right times when I was mentally
ready to study chess and I got these
books of these great authors so for me
it's not just about the titles it's
about the authors that really speak to
me Paul cares was brilliant Alexandra
alakai was brilliant I just love I just
ingested their books with question for
yourself what books played a great role
for you
when I was growing up it was mostly the
world champions books that said my best
games yeah going over those I do too
because when they analyze their own
games you learn so much not just about
Chess but how to analyze your own games
and learn from your mistakes but
recently it's been mostly agar's books a
different series
I love Boris girlfriend's positional
thinking I think that's what it's called
that's my favorite book at the moment
wonderful and VAR for you two questions
for you first of all the most impactful
books in your career and what and
secondly to the viewers question what do
you recommend for the students at St
Louis University books that uh could
help improve them so for first of all
your career books my career books the
very first book I had was in Russian it
was by tigran Petrosian former world
champion it was called strategy of
safety and strategy is safe yes and the
very first game was a French defense
actually game in an ICT variation so
that's the very first book I had and uh
someone just gave it to me when I
started so I went over that book and
that's where I learned about the French
defense and and the other book that had
a lot of influence on me was a karpov's
100 best games so that's another book I
spent a lot of time going over the games
and that helped me a little bit I think
to get to my positional understanding
studying a lot of the carpool and
patriotician games really enjoy that for
the current books we also uh use the
agar books it's got great series and
there is a calculation there is like a
lot of different tests where you have to
find really difficult positions so even
for the Grand Master Master students we
use a lot of the agarth series these are
great books and very good for a very
high level players even to train lovely
uh jump in VAR to the game of Wesley
because it was whispered in my ear that
Wesley didn't sacrifice The Exchange and
I felt almost a physical
anguish when that was stated Queen G3
check was on the board King F1 the table
was set up brilliantly for what we
thought was a winning combination
starting with the move Rook takes D5
let's not get into that he did Play
Bishop to D7 was that an equally good
was that approved by the engine or was
that just a big Miss now Bishop D7
actually lost most of the advantage and
I think the reason he didn't play Yasser
is that move A6 yeah because that was a
hard move to find I want to get to that
position one more time here because it's
easier for us to spot a spot this idea
idea with an engine but during the game
after Knight E3 if you don't see this
move A6 you actually don't have any
advantage and this could be really risky
because at the end of the day if white
just defends his up exchange and a pass
so this move A6 that what makes the big
difference here so perhaps when he got
here he did not see how he can continue
here and that's why but one more line
that was very interesting I want to
point out why Queen E8 move doesn't work
here because this could be a very
logical move because you're pinning
Black's pieces and the reason is black
has this fantastic move Bishop H3 here
and now if you take on A8 you are just
simply getting maybe after Bishop takes
G2 if you go
up to we are going to see the result
yeah you have a repetition as uh
Daniel and Anish and we thought Anish
was in a bit of a pickle but uh they are
made to draw sorry please you continue
let's let's continue yeah Bishop G2
check if you go to G1 92 is a mate and
if Knight takes uh G2 major simply I
made on E2 and another idea was if you
play here the move Rook takes H3
block has the smooth Knight takes Edge
and now there is a threat on F2 so
you're gonna have to give up your queen
but you're losing here in this position
uh it takes Queen H3 for example so I
think that's the reason he just did not
see this move A6 and that's why he
played the move Bishop D7 now most of
the advantage is gone here so Queen A5
is the best move
at some point he wants to play the move
Queen E1 here to try to get rid of the
screen on G3 so Knight D4 is played the
best move
and here's an Rook D1 plate this is this
is I think a good move bringing the Rook
into the game another alternative was to
play the move Queen E1 here
Queenie one Knight E2
and take back with the queen here black
is still better here there is a move F5
here but Rook D1 is played and here
Knight takes E2 you cannot take back
with the King because you're gonna lose
the G2 Pawn so I think what ding is
planning to do is to play this move Rook
H3
try to remove the queen from here and
here actually Wesley is getting really
sharp in this position Wesley has to
come up with the move B6 here it's very
important because if he if you Retreat
your queen let's say you have Queen B8
the only Square actually you also have
the d64 but let's say queen B8 now
suddenly
white has some ideas like this an idea
of six checks that's not fair you take
Knight F6 check you don't want to go to
G4 G7 because sadly you're getting mated
after Queen G5
out of the Clear Blue Sky yeah it's
almost amazing that we see now white is
attacking because before he was just uh
getting made it here and here yeah you
you actually have a draw here after
Queen H5 threatening mate forcing um
H6 Bishop F5 is another idea that leads
to a draw so Queen F7 made
Bishop G7 Queen G6
and now black needs to find the only
move not to lose which is Bishop F5
obvious
Queen takes F5
Rook takes D1
King to E2
now Rook D2 check this is absolutely
crazy yeah crazy and it the line still
continues Queen D6 check now you want to
pick up the the Knight Knight D5 and
queen C5 and then it will be a Perpetual
Adventure here
another result between Jan and Duda we
can see the players discussing uh the
game and if for both players this is a
kind of a disappointing result as they
both needed to win they currently stand
at -1 2 out of five now two and a half
out of six and they need wins right put
us back into the competition also a few
earlier suggested that when you are on a
losing streak you need to just make one
draw to break the streak so that's what
Ian did yeah in this case Jana had lost
two games in a row
um one fellow who happens to be winning
and winning a lot of games is America's
Fabi and let's just take a look at the
current position because after trades
trades A4 Queen B5 was played and it
seems to me that Fabi even though he's
not a pawn up at the moment has
transposed into an ending of rook and
Knight versus Rook at night where he's
calling all the shots here Nazi look at
this The Rook is on this I mean I always
like to do this from a strategical point
of view uh compare Pieces Just direct
okay how's my Rook on C7 versus your
Rook on E8 big Advantage white how's my
night versus on E5 versus the Knight on
C5
that's right black light uh sorry Black
Knight looks fine on C5 but doing what
yeah at night white night looking good
on C4 and or C6 also slightly better
with the Kings so even though you know I
don't have material advantages white at
the moment my feeling is you know this
is playing on one goal I mean there are
two results that are coming out of this
game and uh they're they're in favor of
white yes I mean I think Beast
is not gonna stay there for a very long
time not very long F7 F6 on the on the
board and these are the results so far
two draws out of the pipe game we have
two draws between diac giri and nepodura
and again our tournament leader Fabi
playing against one of his closest
Rivals Ali Reza again a huge game if
Fabi
scores that would be huge I mean that
might just be a sayonara see you later
get a tournament over uh plus three and
fabi's rating will start going through
the roof in the meanwhile world champion
dingler in
we do have B6 on the board B7 B6 on the
board uh is ding climbing back into the
game or is it one of these things where
Wesley is just even though he's played a
few in precisions he's still got
advantage of our I mean uh how how's it
how's how did the engine how does the
engine evaluate the situation engine
evaluates us uh still better for Wesley
not as much here let's take a look at
the critical lines here Queen D2 is the
move in this position the best move for
ding okay so now uh Bishop G4
Bishop G4 yes okay if you take the queen
with Rook takes G3 Knight G3 check
checking the king and now you move the
king to E1 there is Knight to E4 okay so
I end up with two Rooks for the queen
yeah in case you take the nine the best
move is Queen F4 here actually right the
best movie is Queen F4 here
Bishop H5 and after G4 it's it's still
very complicated but we have another
move here looks like he played Queen A6
he didn't Retreat he didn't Retreat yes
Queen A6 and that's not the best move
here ding has six minutes getting a low
on the clock so still a lot of moves to
go here we're still on move number 29
here now Wesley can have a big Advantage
after Bishop takes G4 right uh you have
to take the queen absolutely that's a
knight G3 check
F2 there is Knight E4
so you have to play King E1 or King G1
and now by the way these two interrupt
you've already he did Play Bishop takes
G4 that is on the board on the board yes
okay so please continue so Rook takes G3
Knight G3 right so King E1 is the best
move here because you need to protect
your Rook okay so I think we're gonna
see this and Bishop E6
so black has a rook and two pieces for
the queen yes
I have to add add them up I need my uh
calculators a little bit stuck here uh
so
from a material point of view white also
has a pawn queen and upon for rook and
two pieces I I love the rook in two
pieces in this case this is materially
speaking ding is busted
and he plays the best move one now we
expect Bishop E6 so why doesn't Knight
takes E4 work here anymore oh because
Queen's not on D2 it's not with us
exactly that was what
um is there any you you played Bishop E6
and I think that's an absolutely no no
problem that that that's a reasonable
Knight to seven attribution B6 yeah but
I was thinking I'd like to kick the
queen out of A6
unless there's a knight F6 check could I
be word can I play Bishop C8 Bishop C8
is a possible move his second best move
here yes second best yeah second best
then Queen goes on A4 and now you again
have to move the bishop because yeah I
was trying to avoid Knight C7 don't I
mean give me my cake and let me eat it
too right uh I was if I put my Bishop on
E6 I was I had a slight concern that
Knight C7 was disruptive but maybe that
is just completely wrong you say Bishop
E6 is the best move because after Bishop
C8 Queen a49 you don't have Bishop D7
because of the Knight F7 yeah and Rook
will capture on this sound so you're
gonna have to play this move Bishop E6
uh anyway here so but let's look at the
line here after Bishop B6 go a little
bit deeper into this position because I
think this can really happen here Knight
F4 is another possibility here four
white it's not like the only move is 97
black is better in both variations so
Rook takes D1 check right King takes D1
Rook d a check
sure and now yeah we don't we cannot go
to the C file because of the Rook C8
idea so that will be just a really bad
Rook C8 Queen takes A7 and you have
Bishop D6 winning the Knight right so
you have to go back to E1 only move and
you don't really want to allow the move
Knight E6 here because the bishop is
very strong so you have a move Bishop B3
but this looks devastating because the
Rooks and the minor pieces are working
so well together but surprisingly it's
there's no like immediate way to win the
line continues with Queen A7 okay Rook
D1 check
now King F2
Knight H1 check King E2
and again you have the repetition but in
order to try to play water when you have
to play this move Rook B1 here
and I can take on B6 Rook takes B2 check
King E3 I mean I'm surprised the
engine's not showing a lot more
exactly again block is maybe winning but
not not an easy position to play I'm not
convinced that Wesley will go for this
yeah wow really really really really
remarkable uh another game that's uh
pretty chaotic at the moment is the game
between mvl and Richard uh we had spoken
about this type of a possibility some
time ago sacrificing the A3 Pawn for
white going after the H6 pawn and then
to have that pawn race and then it's
that pond race right and
who knows what's going on in this race
uh VAR clear the cobwebs for us because
this looks like three results absolutely
and it looks like you're going to lose
the eight check spawn but you need a
very quick Contra play with the B4 B5
b55 I thought it was all about the eight
Bond you're saying it's about B5 B5 yeah
Bishop E8 is the best move here okay I
move the bishop here so everything is
protected nice and uh you it doesn't
matter which move you start with Queen
H6 or Knight D1 you're gonna need to put
a knight on the one the one eventually
here so let's say queen takes H6 right
now B5 comes in but I think to play B4
immediately and Knight if you play the
move Knight D1 sorry about to interrupt
but why are we playing B5 because it
looks like a pawn is farther along so
why not push A4 so right here just start
with A4 okay so let's say if you start
with A4 now the problem is the smooth
Queen f8
cleaning your knight so we move our
Queen to A1 A1 okay so we're threatening
we think we're threatening Queen F1
Knight D1 first to prevent that let's go
A3 A3 and now actually I'm threatening
to Queen my palm A2
wait wait wait wait because we can stop
you with Bishop G6
uh Bishop G6 is the best move if you
play two I think we both Queen but my
king is actually better protected
amazing we're gonna have Four Queens on
the board and yes your king is safer
than Mikey okay I get that but yeah
okay that's just a momentary quiet move
I'm gonna play A2 and queen yes but
actually I I'm I'm winning with two
different ways here I can play the move
Queen B8 for example go ahead uh show me
how you're gonna win A2 A2
Queen D6 I've I've got an escape Square
King E8 King E8
Queen takes E6 now
how is this winning oh wow okay so I
could take a good night with check which
I don't want to do I want to have so I
go Queen B1 like a reasonable person
Bishop D5 now I make a queen God
whatever
I'm oh
Queen F6
and queen G7
it's so easy to Miss Chess is cruel yes
look at that look at those Queens I
would I would I could have been a
contender I tell you about absolutely
wow
terrible terrible well okay so the
Richie position
at the end of all of this what is what's
the current evaluation bar zero zero
zero but you have to play B5 before not
the A4 Pawn guys B5 B4 yes you have to
do that and the point is when you play
B5 before when the Knight is on D1 you
don't take one city you just continue
pushing with B3 okay
and of the games remaining what is the
story as far as the clocks who's in time
travel let's switch to Fabi because I
think he's about to win I think alvareza
really misplayed the position here whoa
and Bobby has great chances here so the
clock situation also not good for
alireza he's got 58 seconds to make five
more moves and Fabi is still on the 15
minutes we left the rough around here
after the move um
b695 and here actually what he had to do
he had to try to get into this Rook end
game like you're gonna be yeah you're
going to be losing the the B6 upon here
in some of the sign let's say you play
the smoking G7 okay Knight C4 okay
um
should be Knight A4 Knight A4 Rook B7
and this this was the best way for him
to continue here let's say Rook C8 or
yeah maybe six and I was gonna ask you
yes sir about your opinion about this
end game what do you think of the
chances of trying to hold this it seems
like with more pawns on this side of the
board a white uh has decent chance but
what do you think can uh black really
try to hold this position you know it's
one of those positions I call 50 50. 50
of the chance 50 of the time I think
white is going to win but 50 of the time
I think black is also going to hold so
it's definitely
um holdable but it's also definitely
winnable I would say that Fabi would
like to have tortured his opponent but
that's not what happened what happened
was that for and another thing that I
would have done maybe is I would have
left the king inside alone and maybe
played 94 Knight D6 trying to go after
the B5 Pawn I don't like what we have in
the game which is this move E6 isn't
that just a violently completely open
seventh rank can we just Knight G4 right
that's exactly what I'm thinking too uh
Nasi that after Knight G4 this is really
all black needs isn't to jump from
knight from A4 to D5 and then everything
would be okay but even then I'm not 100
sure you'd have a quality but the Knight
is terrible over on that side of the
board whereas night here I think you
have to play Rook f8 I I really don't
think of there that there's being a
choice Knight H6 put the King on in the
corner yeah Knight H6
keep everything pressed something to be
said for H4 G4 a G5 and white can do
anything here bring the king if you want
black is really really stuck the other
thing here too is you almost start to
think to yourself can't I win a pawn you
know like all of these pawns are lined
up like like ducks in a row right you
start to think can I shouldn't I play
like Rook C6 it looks like Bobby has a
really big advantage and a big advantage
on the clock as well as far Asia will be
playing how many moves uh they have five
more moves to go and feroza has 58
seconds on the clock and that'd be about
10 minutes or 12 minutes okay very good
and the other game uh the games that I
remember dingler in what's the clock
times here Wesley has five minutes they
both have five minutes left on the clock
for how many moves eight more moves more
moves and
after the after King he won Bishop E6
Queen B7 Wesley said I don't like your
queen get out of here Rook C8 and we're
pardon me Rook E8 to B8 we're up to date
with the the players
Queen C7 ding is trying to be his
disturbing best by the way Knight H5
came with speed like uh
this question is definitely easier for
Wesley to play he has so many more
pieces on the board it truly true that
and that's the whole thing I I've always
thought that three minor
pieces versus the queen
slightly favorable mostly for the minor
pieces but there are some exceptions
where the queen is really really
powerful
two minor pieces and a rook for the
queen I've always always felt that
should be very very favorable for the
pieces and enough for the queen G4 and
Wesley
it's not just
uh the piece is two Bishops right two
Bishops and a rook versus queen Knight
F6 last move on the board that
I mean black is basically the the
material count is now preposterously
large
ding is going to need a Perpetual check
to save himself uh here can he get it
far
um no I don't see a Perpetual right now
he has an option to play 97 check which
I think is best option maybe perhaps too
forced to take uh black to take only
seven but king h8 move is also possible
I like him but I'm checking h8 there is
Knight C6 and it's a bit of a strange
position you play Rook C8 and I go Queen
B7 and it's not easy actually to for
black to to just get rid of Michael and
if you do then you're probably just
winning but right not easy to do it so
and Wesley was ready for that I mean
his pen in hand so King h8
Knight C6 1968 for just a moment because
I have a move when I when I have knights
in such positions where I'm facing pawns
on e4 and F3 I don't like the Knight on
F6 so
let me get rid of the queen I might take
on B8 in this case maybe you can take
the queen queen B8
and give the queen back
and normally I would prefer two pieces
Against The Rook yes but in this end
game I do have a pawn and I may also
have Rook d8 very quickly well the other
point is you're currently vulnerable
King is no longer vulnerable after 90.
it's a Pity because I was thinking that
if I could get for example 98 and Rook
C8 then you know I'm unwinding and on a
good day Bishop D6 might even come with
the tempo so Knight C6
Rook C8 Queen B7 most likely to be
played
but let's take a pause and uh
pass the ball to Christian in Romania
we are with Bogdan Daniel at the
acromania's number two Bogdan first of
all a difficult tournament up to this
point for you but today a pretty solid
result against Anish you got some
pressure out of the opening did you
prepare this with your coach this idea
of Bishop E2 Bishop F3 this uh obscure
line in in the night or if one would say
okay hello first of all thank you for
the invitation
I prepare a bit this idea with Bishop F3
okay yeah just to see
H6 Bishop F3 it's the normal move so
what are some of the ideas of this
bishop E2 Bishop F3 plan
to come with A4 A5 92 Knight F1 93 okay
yeah
yes and you actually play that yes so
let's take a look at
the continuation The Rook to E2 gather
on the D file is is it to put pressure
on the D6 Pawn or rather to stop black
from playing D5
what is the main idea behind this both
things to stop D5 and to put pressure on
D6 Pawn
did you feel like he was ready for this
it's a bit unpleasant because in a
normally we went to try D5 yes in
neither yes
by by the way did you expect him to play
the night off yes you did yes so you
thought he's going to
try for a Sharp game today
okay I don't want really a sharp game
today I just want to play normal yes yes
okay Knight to C1
and in fact the engine was giving you a
pretty decent lead at this point
plus one were you feeling that this is a
plus close to a plus one advantage right
now okay you don't feel really plus one
but I feel plus you were feeling like
you were
putting the pressure yes yes probably
here I need to bring instead of P3 to
try H3 Queen B7
Knight G3
here if I try and just to interrupt you
for a second I do believe
we just got a result right now and in
fact
Wesley soft for whatever reason accepted
a draw in this position
unbelievable result he was in fact much
better and perhaps even winning at this
point and he decided to repeat this is
in fact unbelievable turn of events but
we'll we'll catch up with all that drama
in just a second let's finish the
analysis Bogdan I think we we left it
off somewhere around here
please continue yes instead of B3 I
think that H3 Queen B7 Knight G3
here I think at B3 also my T4 C4 Knight
C7
Queen C2 F5 Knight C3 and D5
I don't know what to say because cd5
doesn't work because of 92 and E4 E4
yeah yeah and you cannot take only six
because if I takes F3 with a check yes
okay
very nice good calculation uh you decide
to go for this B3
and
okay probably don't need to play Knight
F5 probably just to continue to play
Queen Nifty
but here I don't like Nike it and come
with Knight on F6 probably the best move
but yes
the engine as well so definitely you
kind of understood exactly what the
requirements of the position uh are and
by the way it's not despite the fact
that the engine is saying that sure
you're better it's not that easy right
yes to make a dent in Black's position
cool all right and you guys exchanged
did anything out of the ordinary happen
in your opinion or at this point you
both have to more or less repeat the
position okay here it's necessary to
read it
because you know I put the G4
I can't I can't I can become easy worse
here with light yes yes Bogdan uh
congratulations up to this point you're
finishing up with Richie Rapport I
believe or dingly ran in the last one
the world champion and there is another
player that you will be facing I don't
remember exactly round deep again mvl
quite a difficult finish how are you
going to approach those games
okay just try to play just try to play
and by the way uh right now the Romanian
national team is having a new coach
Yvonne sokolov he was uh on the other
broadcast as well how is that
partnership going are you enjoying
working with Mr sokolov
I work it's a good relationship
I don't want to see more of course of
course well thank you very much thank
you and we'll see you in the upcoming
rounds thank you guys back to you
Christian thank you Daniel uh we're kind
of reeling uh sorry here folks but we
don't understand what just took place
when we left for the interview we
thought that Wesley was going to
how do you say just play and play and
torture ding with his material advantage
of two men minor pieces in Rook versus
queen instead he agreed to a repetition
I don't know how big an advantage of the
engines were suggesting he had but I'm
rather stunned that Wesley made the
decision he did help us out bar was that
tell me why he did what he did I'm
confused I'm also stunned Yasser I mean
he had a minus two Advantage here in
absolute no risk for him to continue to
grow so really surprising decision
that he tried to bail out let's take a
look uh the end of the game okay through
the magic of Television this is what it
was all about here in 97 check two very
reasonable moves I like King h8
personally I love those Bishops he took
that's fine Queen takes on a real time
travel because they were about to reach
more 40. exactly and black has
absolutely no risk exactly there's a
white king So rookie eight that looks
great so the queen has to move and now
you play H5 you just play H5
you invite the move G5 then you can
reroute the Knight back to G6 you go H5
G5 Knight H7
very very nice your king is completely
solid you've got a solid Queen side
structure solid King side structure
maybe you even go A5 A4 and Bishop B3
Wesley says
maybe one explanation it would be that
he's physically not feeling well that
could be it yeah you never know I mean
we we are suffering here in St Louis I
know that Tony Tony Rich has gone to
Bucharest and also Fallen ill Christian
has spoken about it as well I don't know
maybe something but
I mean from a material point of view I I
haven't seen this and whatever
big big big time and uh ding was like
please please you know you didn't even
know what to do I mean would you would
you like to shake my hand absolutely he
was reluctant to because yeah he he got
away with one today we have two
remaining games uh the tournament lead
it's uh Fabi Fabi has got when we left
it we left it about here I kind of like
the move Rook B7 it's like just one of
those uh little little moves but it just
says okay your night is Frozen uh I'll
make incremental uh
improvements so The Rook was a moment on
C7 now it's on B7 now the knights on G4
Knight H6 King check just uh I guess
it's going to be one more time
repetition or maybe he is thinking about
Knight D6 how serious is are White's uh
winning chances in this game end game
VAR
but uh pause that thought for just a
moment jump to Romania as Christian is
with Wesley and we can ask him what's
going on
Wesley you came here and you were kind
of incredulous about the eval of the
engine being minus three at the end of
the game how did you assess that
position how did you come up to the
conclusion yeah repetition is the best
well no I just thought things went out
of control I mean it doesn't even make
sense looking at the computer these days
because they're just too strong and the
evaluation
is inhuman so totally unrealistic but uh
well I thought the position was very
complicated at that stage I was also
disappointed that I missed a very good
winning chance against the act the other
day so what the next specially hoping
for much today but I thought I got a
good petition and then you were showing
me some lines earlier
like with the exchange sacrifice with
Rook to D5 yeah yeah I found this
from afar and Elsa was calculating it
here after Knight E3 I thought I'm done
and exchange in a pond and um I mean
probably should add more lines here on
the engine so that we know if Asics is
the only way anymore so A6
Queen E1
it takes oh I guess
I didn't say queen G6
or A6 and it's more of a slow burning
Advantage right it doesn't finish in the
next three moves nothing super tactical
yeah yeah I mean
problem is I can't get my Rook so A6
Queen A5 Bishop Queen E1 yeah and I
didn't see Queen G6 it's a slow Retreat
and it's minus four
yeah it's just Knight H5 is a big
problem Rook E8 is a big problem right
now
so if it goes to G3
let's see
ah H5
ah Queen G6 so yeah just totally miss
queen G6 but even Bishop to D7 it was a
good chance
baby Bishop D7 was not clear because I
was calculating so many lines after H4 I
guess H4 is a mistake but it's already
not so easy
uh like I was first of gonna go here
but then I saw Knight D5 Queen G3 King
D2
okay is a bit unrealistic right yeah I
mean
just that's a funny move if it makes
sense look at a computer when you're
when we're playing a human and awesome
how would you describe this Edition
because sure we see this evals is like
minus three minus four or four but
they're not easy to calculate and you
have options at every single move your
opposite has options at every single
move no I thought I had very good I
thought its position was very close to
collapsing
for him for him yeah that if position
can I just couldn't find enough Outlaw
like here I spent 25 minutes thinking uh
Queen F4 looks very tempting but but
yeah the
I was hoping for Queen E3 and then I
would give a check
like I was calculating fine lines like
this
okay it's just completely winning of
course
but it's
easier
said when you have engine right in front
of you but third Queen fortnite D5
but uh yeah I thought a very good chance
today just didn't find The Knockout low
like uh I was talking 94 but 94 is not
enough for a win
because he goes like this he just barely
hang fun but that's the thing even this
position you're still better right yeah
maybe not that as easy but you're still
objectively better yeah but the problem
is we have good choices and you want to
find the one that
that um it's just crashing yeah but yeah
of course I should EX play this exchange
sacrifice I just think Queen G6 but
let's go down to the last few yeah
moments of the game I was very surprised
when you played Rook D1 actually yes
yeah I guess I didn't realize that
because
B7 was at least according to the engine
not the precise move
yeah I I think he started shaking his
head because after King V1 or d8 I
cannot he can play King E1 I guess he
missed
Bishop E7 or Bishop B3
but it's not winning for black
but uh Queen B7 also had a little time
at this point
um
Where Are You Still Still harboring
hopes for for an advantage here or were
you ready to kind of
as possible
well it wasn't 100 Venture I was playing
for a win that's the problem also I was
getting low on time I mean of course if
I have some chance I would push it yeah
but here I was calculating Queen B7 then
I couldn't find how to untangle because
after 98 he's got e5s
yeah this is not easy anymore
yeah because with my knight on E8
I'm not sure also how strong this engine
is because usually
yeah you have to give at least like that
30 that 35 to be accurate but I didn't
realize the disposition is plus two hmm
like I thought he's got a phone
for a queen and three pieces I guess
three pieces but
yeah just like push the pawns maybe G5
but F4 try to to get something on the
king side that's white right
it does look a little bit dangerous
for for you if you manages to push your
pieces out
I still have no idea what's uh going on
today finally this is plus two
because the bishop an E6 defense
everything
but of course it's now that I see the
evaluation is very stupid for me to
repeat but during the game I wasn't
a hundred percent sure is
who's better or how much better I really
am age Yeah you mentioned that at the
beginning that you were a bit
disappointed about the result again
spoke down uh in the previous round uh
this is sure another misstep objective
misstep how are you going to deal with
um the psychological blow
well I've been doing this for eight and
a half years but it's just another day
in the office for me I mean obviously I
wanted better I thought ding wasn't in
good shape in this tournament like when
he started making all these bad moves in
the opening like Queen very aggressive
yeah I mean E4 you should just try to
I don't know like I guess he didn't want
to
make a draw so early in the game
so that's why I played E4 but only white
could run into trouble here
um so well just take it day at the time
I still get plenty of tournaments left
in the year and just as I say St Louis
just try to keep getting better day by
day and hope that things go your way but
I'm very pleased that my competitor at
Fabiana is doing
extremely well in this tournament I
think the last two times between Romania
or the last three times actually didn't
go well but
very glad that he's winning almost every
game here but it's a Pity that I didn't
convert today it would have been a big
treat beating the world champion but
yeah I still find it very stupid that I
repeated moves in this position but yeah
without the engine you know the engine
is not that easy to to assess this
imbalance positions Wesley yeah actually
thing if you ask random GM what they
think
of the assessment this position I I
don't think anyone would give blessed to
do for black and maybe we can throw that
question to uh to the guys in St Louis
Wesley thank you very much yeah thank
you so much for having me
thank you Christian thank you Wesley it
goes to show Nazi what a very very
difficult game chess is that one of the
very best players in the world came to a
position and misevaluated uh the
position uh but here we have uh the
results thus far three yeah we have
three draws between the akiri right and
the surprise and draw between Ding and
stuff as we get prepared to go on a
break we've got two games left uh very
surprising situation suddenly occurring
between Fabi and Ali Reza I really
thought the end game that Fabi had had
as in past tense was really good for him
after the move F5 he played Knight C4
and that was a strange move because Ian
just invited rookie Rook F7 trading
Rooks again those those the those uh
things that I do all the time I I weigh
the various pieces The Rook on f8 is
terrible compared to the Rook on B7 as a
defender of the position I would be
elated to get rid of the Rooks and if I
could trade the Rooks I get a draw and
it's forced now you can't avoid the
rookies he can't avoid you don't create
just a rook effect right Rook B8 Rook f8
after coin exchange maybe Fabi thinks
that he has a big advantage in the night
and okay
I'm sure he did I'm sure he did you're
talking about an earlier point right
here Queen takes Pawn takes Knight here
Rook here night here yeah I'm sure he
felt that hey I should be winning this
or uh pressing right but in the current
position we have rookie Rook Cafe on the
board
yes and this this is a line where
analyze it oh no it did happen Okay so
after The Rook Exchange
f8 or on F7 let's say on f8 okay and
white tries to bring the king over to
the queen side as soon as possible well
what but it's too slow because black
king is right there well black is also
ready to trade uh four versus four will
be uh the nine ending uh that will be
easy draw white doesn't even have a
chance to keep trying no I think uh
we're about to see a handshake and
repetition as Bobby is just coming to
this horrifying realization and there
you see it just right there where the
with the Grimace of the head shake uh
that so what was the mistake exactly
well right here you you you the funny
part is black is kind of stuck for a
move like you you might just for example
consider the move H forward
or king of three just go ahead let's
improve our position incrementally right
if you want to play F5 maybe you're
inviting my king and there you see it
Bobby is a repeating and for farrugia
yep yep we're about to see yeah
he's probably going to be signing the
score sheet with a very big smile on his
face so we almost had two wins two
Americans almost one today exactly they
had instead and there's the hardware and
clasp uh the ones that get away VAR this
is a and there you see a big smile pump
from Perugia saying dude man this is
really bad I know I let you off the hook
and we have one game remaining which is
a crazy game
but we we we we hope to get an interview
with Bobby but uh vard's way in there on
the Wesley so interview because
I think for a lot of people in the
audience they're going to be shocked
that Wesley
didn't have
I want to say confidence in his material
plus and they're asking why why didn't
Wesley believe he was much better I
agree yesterday I think it also had to
do with who he was playing if he was
playing somebody like 2600 Grand Master
I don't see him repeating that position
no he's going to wipe them out and yeah
he's just gonna play H5 and he you know
forced G5 like you mentioned Knight H7
and I don't see any losing chances there
for him so he could have just repeat and
he really has a drawing in a pocket in
that position and I think just the fact
he was playing England and he he thought
he lost control of the game and just
decided to play it safe
uh but yeah definitely a decision that
could uh hunt him back because that was
an opportunity for him and as for as far
as for Fabiano's game the position you
have currently he has a really big
Advantage right there if he plays your
move H4 and slowly try to improve the
position but the last move uh the the
big blunder was the move when he allowed
this move Rook F7 here I want to go back
to that position here when he played
this move Knight C4 here he still has an
advantage here it's a little bit less
than before but with the move Rook C7 he
can keep this knight from going to C3 or
anywhere and also if the move Rook d8
comes he puts the Rook on C6 so this is
still a very uh pretty nice Advantage
here and really good winning chances for
him he has ideas such as F4 bring the
king to F3 but I think he's simply when
he played the move Knight C4 he just
overlooked this idea and this is really
really disappointing because this was a
big chance for him to try to win this
game and here he has to actually read
repeatedly because at some point if he
trades Rooks here uh this keeps can this
King can come and
you have to be careful but there is no
winning chances of course you also have
the Knight C3 options so really a
strange misstep here you know with
having a lot of time on the clock here
just uh for a second perhaps he lost
concentration and just missed this move
Rook F7 and the game immediately ended
in a draw after that missed
opportunities which leaves us with our
remaining game which has been a Donny
Brook by the way uh lots of fun things
going on in this game
has this race uh of uh pawns on the
h-bond versus the B Pawn and uh
it was funny because I think now see you
and I both have the same impression
excuse me but my a Pawn's more advanced
let me just get my queen out of the way
so I can make the queen and VAR was
saying no no no no be push your beep on
and that's exactly what happened he's
pushed his B Pawn has Richard and now in
his mind he's dreaming of
dropping in and playing Queen A2 take C2
now in this position
what is MBL gonna do what's he gonna do
either take home B3 or push H6 does
similar right
um taking on B3 kind of exposes the king
a little bit uh would you I'd be more
accurated to play H6 myself how would
the line go after H6 do I play Bishop G6
stop the guy
you can also take on C2 to expose white
skin more
B takes you too yeah should I take it I
I mean the I was thinking
take on C2 expose the king more
oh you're not playing Bishop A4 on me
are you no I I wish
okay I I'll take maybe Queen A2 check
okay now here I got a problem if I go
here I got Queen B3 check so I have to
drop back with my king
King to C1
and
I don't know how close yeah to winning
but how oh which one is really fast
right so we'll go back to this position
right and I like the pawn on B3 what if
I just
chill uh Bishop G6 stopping the H Pawn
setting up for a very quick the only
reason I don't like holding the bishop
is that it allows White Queen to go from
behind maybe Queen B8 at some point ah
we saw something like this before right
okay
yeah and queen or
what about H7 I'm throwing the pawn away
wait a minute wait a minute gift meet
upon just a second make me happy and I
think I want to play Bishop H5
who invited you to the party Bishop H5
look at you uh cuckoo kachoo uh wait a
minute I'm gonna have to stop you Bishop
G6
so oh you're pinned you're not stopping
me
oh my goodness I am thin you're
absolutely right Bishop takes G6 okay
good morning Saint Louis ah that was
that was nice oh my goodness uh as we're
getting uh set up for interview with
Bobby uh there watch out so there is
danger lurking as well for Richie uh
Jump Right In VAR
um as a French defense player come on
you know you gotta fight for the honor
of uh the queen side attack what's going
on
um yeah the I think it's evaluation is
zero zero zero as as usual but there are
some lines here there's some ways to to
uh players to make mistake like that
line for example Bishop G6 H7 and
suddenly white is winning there so mvl
just played C takes B3 so now let's see
how black should continue here
so for example he has two options he can
play Queen A2 and also he can take on B3
so if he takes so he takes B3 expected
H6 to try to advance the pawn now again
there are multiple moves here B2 is for
example is is equal Queen A2 check is
also equal because if you go King E1
and now you have to find the only move
here Queen H2
wow the idea is to prevent uh uh the
move H7
and now white needs to go Bishop E2 now
blockading the second rank so if you
play B2 I can capture at some point I'm
also threatening now Bishop B5 check and
there is a queen H4 check here
if you go King F1 I can continue I can
also take one F4 with the check so it
basically will lead to a Perpetual here
um if you try to escape with
King D2
and black has this who Bishop H5
activating the bishop here Bishop B5
check I just go King C7 and now the
queen is protecting the E7 Knight
that's why I mentioned it's really
complicated here some of these moves are
not very natural here and if you take on
H5 Queen takes H5
both players have very Advanced pass
pawns and now
you can play the move Queen G7 and that
leads to Queen H2 check or you can play
let's say Knight
F2
and we're going to go to Romania
Christian has an interview
thanks for uh Ali Reza back-to-back
victories before this round but today
you are on the ropes defending with
black pieces early on against Fabia
player that you don't have a very good
uh result against in general how did you
approach this matchup what was the
strategy going into today's round yeah
um for sure fin fabies on form it's very
difficult to play against him
he has crazy results when he's on forms
and and today he really played amazing
chess and I was under the pressure under
pressure the whole game so and I was
kind of very lucky to escape the drawing
today and yeah the opening was
I think he made a very good opening
choice but I I knew this line from
before and up to C5 yeah yeah before
yeah I think I don't remember exactly
but I think these are all correct
and
um it's not an easy position yeah right
I think I'm
there is a bit more correct way probably
instead of here but it should be okay
um yeah but white is a white has an edge
here so it's not easy and
you put a lot of pressure here
95 is interesting move yeah here
probably
after Queen D5 is probably a mistake and
yeah there's F6 Queen D6 should be equal
I'm I was a bit too optimistic here and
I played this queen D5 and he played
this amazing so what are the risks that
you're taking and in this position my
knight on A5 is terrible and it's always
out of the game and my king could be
weak with Knight G4 always and horn on
F7 if I move the Rook it the whole
problem is Knight on A5 and Pawn on B7
and his pieces are very good well
managed here and I don't have a good
place for my queen so I had to solve all
of this but it was not possible
and his King is a bit safer as well
right yeah but I think I could have
solved it tactically here
okay it is good move
93. no you're you are defending very
well at this point yeah here I said I am
probably lost
really that's how you assessed it yeah
because it's very inactive for my pieces
but I I always have chance but was it
also because of the time situation yeah
and all the time decision but I thought
it's very hopeless my position
especially
here after 93 is a great move
um
I couldn't find anything better because
I couldn't assist it after for instance
King F7 Knight D5
[Music]
if I give up the phone I said I'm lost
so but Knight C5 yeah it takes 96
rupee seven he could keep the pawn
somehow
and I said this is very hopeless
with computer of course defense somehow
and also Knight C3 yeah yeah it's very
hopeless in his position practically at
least computer maybe could defend but
practically I said Isis is my only
chance but of course it should be
Loosely The Rook on C7 but yeah
afraid he was also getting in time
trouble here and he couldn't find the
best line but I'm sure my Jeep he has to
play for maid here E4 H4 F4 everything
maybe like Knight H6 getting King to h8
and then push the pawns basically you
can bring the king to C4
and he has all the time in the world it
seems like right yeah he was he wanted
to finish the game quickly I think so
you guys actually got to move like 41.
yeah yeah and that's where the big
mistake came with this move Knight to C4
he was out of danger in terms of his
time situation right yeah he got the 40
moves
actually he played Knight C4 and he put
it back so oh so he did play it and he
realized that in the exact moment yeah
it was a cold shower description yeah
yeah of course I think if he plays Rook
season I will lose the game slowly
slowly
just Rook seven and then yeah
King comes E5 is Big it was just luck
here that he missed Knight C4 when he
got time
30 minutes yeah yeah
um well luck is definitely necessary in
chess occasionally right
um still a great result for you with
black pieces you still have a couple of
uh whites left what's the strategy
what's the plan for the last three
rounds the championship rounds yeah
always in every tournament the last
three rounds are the most important and
it's a decider so I'm happy I have two
whites
and I will try to play good chess I
cannot change anything and I have to try
my best and we will see what happens one
more question actually because we had
another very weird instance it was this
game between dingley Rand and Wesley
first of all ding went completely
Out For Blood yeah with like Knight F4
E4 F3 just trying to push his pieces in
the center
it seemed like he was completely winning
at one point and I want to ask you about
the last
moment of the game where Wesley was in
fact winning but he decided to repeat
did you look did you see this position
in the play Hall at all you were focused
on your game yeah I had a lot of
problems like focus on other games but
yeah it's weird and he decides a lot of
uh intriguing things are happening today
in today's round is it the energy levels
is it like uh the day after the rest day
yeah this is typical Wesley he wins one
game in the tournament and makes drawn
but this is weird this he has to drive
thank you for uh joining us we'll see
you in the next rounds and we're going
to take a short commercial break and
we'll be back with the final moments of
the last game the one between Max
investor on the ground and Richie report
we'll be back shortly don't go anywhere
[Music]
thank you
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back to round six of
Superbad chess classic
the game has just ended the fifth and
final game between nvl and Richie report
the players have been making a
repetition they stopped the clock and
this will be the fifth out of fifth
round of the five games and I gotta tell
you there was a lot of fight in a lot of
these games we expected wins at least
two at least two we didn't get them but
we sure got a fighting round instead as
it is now officially a draw yeah
this is the first time we've had all
five draws I think so yeah we we've
usually had one game sometimes two
sometimes three but at least one game
per round has been decisive and we
really thought that Juan Fabiano was
going to be extending his lead because
he had such a wonderful end game
position but literally in three moves he
just blew it and he was so upset with
himself he didn't even go for the
interview thereafter faruja was happy to
explain how he held the position but it
wasn't easy now Wesley so on the other
hand he's going to be disappointed
because he had the opportunity in our
opinion of actually playing maybe the
game of the year if he had come up with
that exchange sacrifice and looked at it
a little bit deeper as he explained in
the post-game press uh conference there
with Christian he missed the he missed
the important move Queen G6 and if he
had stopped and he reflected on it it
would have been marvelous VAR uh an
eventful day but in the end nobody
really landed the punch absolutely I
missed opportunities yes sir both for
Fabiano and for Wesley yeah and uh you
know and Fabiano had this great end game
he played really well to got that
advantage and there's in just a few
moves uh blew it away by just making
that inaccuracies and especially that
final move Knight C4 which is very
unpleasant where he allowed a draw
immediately
with six rounds under our belt and this
standing is going to look a lot
different if you're thrown in a couple
of Victories there for Wesley and Bobby
but as it is let's see what as it is
with the updated current scores the
standings are exactly the same as they
were this morning absolutely Bobby's
still living with plaster score
following Khloe mostly fioriciouso and
Robert that feels like a tenuous half
point lead doesn't it because a lot of
things going on underneath and with 50
we have Gary and mvl right and still
trying to catch out for two and a half
Nepal Ding and Duda exactly for dingler
in our inning world champion unable to
score that's that's tough predictions
this is not my finest moment uh neither
yours VAR yeah absolutely a Christian
looks quite satisfied with his choice
right as is Irish mvl
some chances today how did you feel
about your pick honestly at some point I
was worried for him a little bit because
he could have gone the other way right
you're always a fine herself okay very
good but let's throw it to Christian in
Bucharest for some final thoughts about
a very eventful Realm
well uh the standings haven't changed
but you know there are a couple of
players that are definitely disappointed
with uh the final results of these games
in particular uh of course Wesley so and
Fabiano caruana I mean Wesley he just
couldn't believe it he didn't want to
leave the studio he was just like
looking at the engine and trying to
understand how is the engine saying that
this position is a minus two minus four
a few moves before that he was just
simply uh incredulous about the outcome
I'm not 100 sure what happened but it
was a day of weird occurrences and of
course uh that move Knight to C4 at move
41 it wasn't at move 40 it wasn't the
last move before the time control it was
the first move after the time control
what you have to do at that point is
just take a break go the restroom get
yourself some tea sip on that tea and
try to understand the position try to
understand where you are and just play
The Right Move It was a cold shower as
Ali Reza described it Knight to C4 you
understand
that you just spoiled your whole
Advantage but the problem is once you
touch the Knight there's no turning back
there's nowhere to put the Knight you
cannot go to C8 you actually don't have
any other squares for the Knight but C4
unless you want to lose a piece so it's
just a very
um disappointing result for Fabiano who
with a victory was sort of running away
with the event we saw him smile chat a
little bit with alireza but I can
guarantee you he was quite disgusted
with his Knight to C4 his final move at
move 41. just an incredible day of Chess
uh some weird instances but still three
rounds to go and I'm very excited to see
what these players are going to bring
thank you thank you Christian once again
standings nothing changed Bobby's still
on the top with chasing pack of wolves
and only three more rounds to go and
only three and tell us about tomorrow's
round uh the pairings for round seven
right let's take a look we have Duda
against mvl somebody's got to win some
games uh come on ferrusha against the
Palm Desert
and the biggest fight probably Wesley
saw against Fabio Carolina exactly
Wesley with the white pieces may be
trying to put some damage on fabby's uh
achievements thus far right and we have
giri versus ding
still haven't scored so they will try to
do that tomorrow a Richie very very
quietly maintaining that second place
and guess what he's playing against the
player Daniel Day akus who's doing worse
maybe maybe Opportunity Knocks for
Richie and as we get ready to close the
broadcast bar we're going to give you
opportunity to get in the final word
about today's round six uh definitely a
quiet round with five draws the first
first time we actually had all games
ending the draw here uh two big missed
opportunities by Wesley saw and Fabiano
caruana and they're going to play each
other tomorrow so that should be a very
interesting matchup if Wesley wants to
win this tournament he needs to try to
get some chance against Fabiano so I'm
excited to see how that game is gonna
unfold thank you thank you Nasi I'm
enjoying our commentary so much thank
you so very much for for being here in
St Louis and making the event so much
fun oh thanks so much I'm I'm really
loving it great and thank you all for
joining us uh tell your friends where
you're hanging out come with your
current questions tomorrow as we have
round seven of the super bet tournament
we'll see you all tomorrow good night
see you tomorrow
foreign
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited